[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur LCP pour
suivre le discours sur l'état de l'Union
de la présidente de la Commission
européenne la présidente du Parlement
européen Roberta mezzola va ouvrir dans
quelques instants à Strasbourg la
première session plénière du Parlement
après la poséeivale et puis elle va
ensuite tout de suite donner la parole à
Ursula wander lion pour ce discours sur
l'état de l'Union c'est une intervention
qui a lieu chaque année au même moment
pour faire le bilan de l'année et puis
se projeter sur l'année en cours mais
évidemment cette année et bien il y a un
caractère un petit peu particulier à
cette intervention c'est le dernier
discours de l'état de l'Union de
Ursula wander lionne puisque nous sommes
à quelques mois des élections
européennes elle se tiendront le 9 juin
prochain et à cette date et bien ce
seront 450 millions de citoyens
européens qui seront appelés aux urnes
afin de de désigner les 705 membres du
Parlement européen alors pour essayer et
bien de décrypter ce discours et puis
derrière les intentions politiques
d'Ursula vendeur lion j'accueille sur ce
plateau Sylvain cade bonjour bonjour et
merci d'être avec nous vous allez
m'accompagner tout au long de cette
matinée vous êtes professeur à Sciences
Po spécialiste de l'Europe et auteur de
l'histoire de la construction de
l'Europe depuis 1945 et 7 au pif alors
dites-nous tout simplement au début quel
est le BUT finalement d'un discours sur
l'état de l'Union je dirais assez
classiquement comme son nom l'indique
est à l'Union européenne il s'agit pour
la présidente de la commission ou le
président quand c'est un homme c'était
yunker avant à la fois de faire le bilan
de l'année qui vient de s'écouler
puisque c'est un discours annuel et puis
de faire de présenter un peu le
programme ou les perspectives du travail
que compte mener la Commission
européenne c'est un peu la Commission
européenne l'exécutif européen alors là
comme vous l'avez dit c'est une année un
peu particulière
c'est très probablement le dernier
discours de sur l'état de l'Union d'ours
Lafontaine donc c'est pas impossible
qu'elle en profite pour faire un peu son
bilan et en même temps peut-être qu'elle
est en campagne c'est-à-dire elle ne le
dit pas parce que évidemment comme elle
est en responsabilité à la surtout pas
intérêt à sortir du bois mais peut-être
est-elle candidate à sa succession ça
c'est arrivé de l'or a fait deux mandats
avant lui Einstein a fait deux mandat
Barroso a fait demanda et on voit
justement sur ces images Robert
tametzola donc présidente du Parlement
européen et Ursula wander lionne
présidente de la Commission européenne
qui arrive ensemble donc au Parlement
européen et qui salue évidemment
différents responsables de partir et du
Parlement elles vont s'exprimer dans
quelques instants alors vous le disiez
elle est peut-être candidate à sa
réélection mais tout dépendra des
nouveaux rapports de force après les
élections européennes un petit état des
lieux aujourd'hui il y a combien de
groupes c'est quoi les rapports de force
au Parlement européen alors les rapports
de force au Parlement européen et c'est
ça qui est intéressant c'est que lors
des élections précédentes des élections
sortantes on va dire
il n'y avait pas comme depuis le début
des élections européennes en 79 une
majorité entre guillemets avec les deux
immenses groupes que sont les
socialistes d'une part et les démocrates
chrétiens et conservateurs d'autre part
donc le PP cette fois-ci pour avoir une
majorité et donc faire passer des textes
il fallait en plus qu'il y ait toujours
le vote ou les votes des membres d'un
troisième groupe parlementaire et
c'était en général
ce qu'on appelait win you Europe
c'est-à-dire le groupe dans lequel il y
a les macronistes pour noter les
spectateurs français qui correspond en
fait au libéraux alors parfois on dit
libéraux parfois on dit centriste
certains connaissent peut-être
différents ministres belges qui a très
très bien incarné cette famille
politique et puis aussi de temps en
temps il y avait les vers qui était la
quatrième ou la cinquième force
politique selon on va dire un peu les
moments donc voilà on peut dire que sur
la fin de harleyon a réussi à incarner
une espèce de majorité plus large que
précédemment où il y avait à la fois les
démocrates chrétiens elle-même en est
issu elle a été ministre de la Défense
en particulier dans Gala Merkel avant
d'accéder à ce poste donc elle est
vraiment démocrate chrétienne allemande
il y avait donc la démocrates chrétiens
les socialistes mais aussi les centrices
libéraux de winiu et de temps en temps
les Verts donc elle a du coup également
réussi à incarner sans doute un
programme de européenne et d'Union
Européenne le plus écolo possible de ces
30 dernières années pour donc je pense
que c'est fort de ce disons de se
positionnement qu'elle peut apparaître
dans une certaine position un peu de
force et un peu singulière à la fin de
son premier mandat voilà c'est il
faudrait pas qu'elle soit uniquement la
candidate du PPE
parce qu'elle a la capacité me
semble-t-il même s'il y aura un candidat
socialiste un candidat vert etc
alors évitez mon là il y a une
présidente qui a été marquée par des
événements importants le covid événement
exceptionnel il y a la guerre en Ukraine
qui continue quel bilan vous feriez de
la présidence vendeur lionne justement
vous le soulignez
pour cela fond de derlion on peut le
dire comme ça a été la femme de la
situation c'est à dire que déjà elle est
arrivée dans les circonstances que
j'indiquais à l'instant c'est à dire
qu'elle a réussi lorsqu'elle a été
investie par le parle européen il y a 4
ans et demi maintenant elle est parvenue
à se faire investir par une majorité
plus large que son groupe est l'habituel
compromis ou entendre technique avec les
socialistes ça c'est déjà une réussite
en soi et c'est surtout assez singulier
deuxièmement comme vous le soulignez
elle a été à la tête de la commission et
donc de l'UE au moment d'événements
totalement inattendus totalement
exceptionnel et qui ont été soit une
crise comme le covid soit un choc
extérieur totalement incroyable et
inattendu encore une fois à savoir
l'invasion de l'Ukraine par l'État russe
et dans les deux cas il me semble
qu'elle a su incarner l'Europe alors ça
veut dire quoi un carnet l'Europe ça
veut dire que d'abord elle a elle est
parvenue à donner un visage et une voix
à un certain nombre de décisions quand
bien même c'était pas elle qui les
prenait parce que
le système politique institutionnel
européen est assez baroque assez
complexe il y a beaucoup de centres de
décision la Commission ne décide pas
tout loin de là souvent c'est le Conseil
européen des chefs d'État est le
gouvernement parfois le Parlement pèse
aussi beaucoup mais elle a réussi à
incarner ça beaucoup plus par exemple
que Charles Michel qui est son homologue
président du Conseil européen des chefs
d'État et de gouvernement l'ancien
Premier ministre belge bon d'autre part
il est vrai qu'elle a été me semble-t-il
on peut discuter
efficace elle est assez décrié en
interne parce que il y a un certain
nombre disons d'acteurs internes qui
considèrent que elle a un mode de
gouvernement qui est un peu solitaire un
peu replié un peu vertical un peu replié
sur son premier cercle bon ça moi je
suis pas tellement capable
non je dirais pas ça je crois pas parce
que du point de vue des résultats vous
en parliez le fait est que pendant
qu'elle était président alors faut-il
dire pendant qu'elle était présidente ou
sous sa présidence il y a eu toute la
panoplie qui a été mis en place pour
lutter contre le covid la pandémie avec
le plan européen de vaccination et les
conséquences qui était une première de
se mettre d'accord pour autant que je
l'ai compris la Commission en tant que
tel et en particulier Thierry Breton
mais toute la Commission a joué vraiment
un rôle si vous voulez la Commission
européenne il faut bien voir que de
toute façon c'est toujours les seuls en
cas de crise européenne quand je dis la
commission je parle de tous les
fonctionnaires pas seulement du collège
des 27 commissaires que dirige madame
vanderleyen c'est toujours les seuls
fonctionnaires qui bossent 7 jours sur 7
24 heures sur 24 sur les affaires
européennes donc il y a un moment donné
quand vous avez une commission qui est
efficace avec des dirigeants qui savent
où ils vont c'est eux qui prennent la
main si je vous écoute on a l'impression
d'un bilan assez positif pour autant
bonjour
ce matin
je suis très heureuse de pouvoir
accueillir la présidente de la
Commission européenne je vous invite à
bien vouloir prendre place pour cette
occasion importante s'il en est
je suis très heureuse de pouvoir
accueillir madame la Présidente de la
Commission européenne sous la fin de
vers la hyène bienvenue ici au Parlement
européen pour le discours annuel sur
l'état de l'Union européenne
ces dernières années nous avons été à
même de surmonter une crise financière
et une pandémie nous avons traversé le
brexit nous avons trouvé de nouvelles
voies pour aller de la bande nous sommes
dressés nous avons tenu bon passe à
cette invasion illégale et brutale de
l'Ukraine par la Russie
nous nous sommes sevrés de notre
dépendance face à l'énergie russe
toxique et nous avons jeté les bases
pour les années à venir l'Union
européenne est aujourd'hui plus forte et
plus unique elle ne l'a jamais été le
monde change et l'Europe à vocation à
s'adapter et à changer avec le monde il
faut que nous poursuivions nos efforts
visant à faire de l'Europe un lieu
d'égalité de chance un lieu d'accès et
un lieu de prospérité où chacun peut
réaliser son potentiel il faut que nous
poursuivions nos réformes nous avons
parcouru un long chemin certes mais trop
de femmes dans l'Union européenne lutte
en côte encore trop de femmes se
heurtent encore à des barrières injustes
trop de jeunes sont encore confrontés à
un avenir incertain nous devons faire en
sorte que les préoccupations ne nous
concitoyennes et concitoyens restent au
cœur de toutes nos actions pour
souligner comment nous y parviendrons
j'ai le plaisir de vous présenter la
présidente de la Commission européenne
qui prononcera son allocution sur l'état
de l'Union européenne en 2023 qui pour
la première fois et je suis extrêmement
fier de pouvoir le dire sera également
interprété en langue internationale des
signes pour cela vous avez la parole
madame la Présidente
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre je suis un député
300 jours les Européens se rendront aux
urnes dans notre démocratie unique et
remarquable
dans toute élection ce sera pour les
citoyens le moment de réfléchir à l'état
de notre union et au travail accompli
par ceux qui les représentent
il y aura parmi eux des millions de
Primo électeurs
dont les plus jeunes sont nés en 2008
à l'époque de la crise économique et
financière
dans l'isoloir il réfléchiront à ce qui
est important pour les réfléchirons à la
guerre qui fait rage à nos frontières
pour les effets destructeurs du
changement climatique
à la façon dont l'intelligence
artificielle influencera leur vie
ou alors chance de trouver un logement
ou un emploi dans les prochaines années
notre union aujourd'hui reflète la
vision de ceux qui ont rêvé de l'avenir
meilleur après la Seconde Guerre
mondiale
une union des nations des démocraties et
des peuples
oeuvreraient de conserve partage de la
paix de la prospérité
la réponse à l'appel de l'histoire
quand je parle à la nouvelle génération
de jeunes l'heure actuelle je vois cette
même vision dans l'avenir meilleur ce
même désir ardent de construire quelque
chose de mieux
même conviction que dans un monde
incertitude
l'Europe doit une fois de plus répondre
à la fin de l'histoire
et c'est ce qu'il nous faut faire
ensemble
gagner la confiance des Européens pour
répondre à leurs inspiration à leurs
inquiétudes
et
dans ces 300 prochains jours il faudra
terminer le travail qui les ont confié
je tiens à remercier
cette assemblée
son rôle de premier plan dans la mise en
oeuvre des transformations les plus
ambitieuses que l'Union est jamais
entreprises
lorsque je me suis présenté à vous en
avec ma programme pour une lampe verte
numérique et géopolitique
je sais que certaines doutes
comme ça c'était avant que le monde ne
bascule dans une pandémie mondiale et
une guerre brutale sur le sol européen
géopolitique qui soutient l'Ukraine qui
s'oppose à l'agression russe
réagit à la fertilité de la Chine et qui
investit dans des partenariats
nous avons à présent un pacte vert pour
l'Europe qui est la pièce maîtresse de
notre économie et dont l'ambition est
sans pareille nous avons tracé la voix
de la transition numérique et nous
sommes devenus les pionniers mondiaux
des droits en ligne
nous avons mis en place le Play story
next generation you avec 800 milliards
d'euros pour financer la fois les
investissements et des réformes et qui
créent des emplois descend pour
aujourd'hui pour demain
nous avons jeté les bases d'une union de
la santé
qui nous ont aidés à vacciner tout un
continent et de basse région du monde
nous avons commencé alors un plus
indépendant dans des secteurs critiques
comme l'énergie les plus électroniques
les matières premières
et je tiens aussi à vous remercier
pour le travail novateur et pionnier que
nous avons accompli en matière d'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes
et en tant que femme ça signifie
beaucoup pour moi
nous avons conclu des dossiers que
beaucoup pensaient bloqués à jamais
comme la directive sur la présence des
femmes des conseils d'administration et
l'adhésion historique de lieu à la
Convention d'Istanbul
avec la directive sur la transparence
des rémunérations nous avons inscrit
dans le droit le principe fondamental
selon lequel un travail égal salaire
égal
mais il ne reste encore beaucoup à
accomplir et il faut continuer ensemble
à rechercher le programme
et je sais
que vous êtes d'accord avec ma
préparation de lutter contre femme et là
aussi
ce que j'aimerais c'est que nous
inscrivions dans le droit à notre
principe fondamental
non c'est non
il peut pas y avoir de véritables
égalité si nous sommes pas libérés de la
violence
[Applaudissements]
nous avons traduit en action plus de 90%
des orientations politiques que j'avais
présenté en 2019
ensemble nous avons montré que quand
l'Europe est audacieuse et unie elle
fait avancer les choses ça te travaille
éloigne d'être terminée donc
unissons-nous obtenons des résultats
aujourd'hui et préparons demain
il y a 4 ans
le pack vert pour l'Europe c'était notre
réponse à l'appel de l'histoire et cet
été
en Europe on a été un douloureux rappel
la Grèce et l'Espagne ont subi des
incendies ravageurs avant d'être frappé
à nouveau quelques semaines plus tard à
peine par des inondations dévastatrices
nous avons été les témoins du chaos du
carnage créé par des conditions
météorologiques extrêmes de la Slovénie
et la Bulgarie et surtout le territoire
de notre réunion c'est la réalité d'une
planète en ébullition
le pacte vert pour l'Europe est né de
cette nécessité de protéger notre
planète
occasion de préserver notre prospérité
future
nous avons entamé ce mandat en fixant
une perspective à long terme avec la loi
sur le climat et l'objectif à l'horizon
nous avons fait évoluer le programme
matière de climat vers brame économique
et cela donne un signal clair concernant
la direction à prendre en matière
d'investissement et d'innovation et nous
avons déjà vu sur le court terme les
résultats de cette stratégie de
croissance
montre chaque jour qu'elle est prête à
faciliter cette transition
en faisant la preuve que la
modernisation et la décarbonation
peuvent aller de pairs
propres dans l'Union européenne est
passé de 0 à 38
où nous attirons aujourd'hui davantage
d'investissement dans l'hydrogène propre
que les États-Unis la Chine réunit
et demain je serai au Danemark avec la
première ministre méthode pour voir
cette innovation de premièrement
le célèverons le lancement du premier
porte-conteneur fonctionnant méthanol
propre fabriqué à partir d'énergie
solaire
là
est la force de la réponse européenne au
changement climatique
les investissements nécessaires mais ce
sont les citoyens les inventeurs les
ingénieurs qui élaborent les solutions
et c'est pourquoi mesdames et messieurs
députés
alors que nous entrons dans la nouvelle
phase du pacte maire pour l'Europe une
chose ne changera pas nous continuerons
à soutenir la defet européenne tout au
long de cette transition
et ils peuvent compter sur eux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec notre stratégie industrielle nous
examinons les risques et les besoins de
chaque écosystème dans le cas de cette
transition nous devons terminer ce
travail
et à partir de là
écosystème industriel
donc à partir de ce mois nous
organiserons une série de dialogues sur
la transition propre avec l'industrie
l'objectif principal sera d'aider chaque
secteur
à élaborer son modèle économique
en vue de la décarbonation de
l'industrie parce que nous croyons que
cette transition est essentielle pour
garantir la compétitivité future de
notre Europe
et la concerne les personnes les emplois
notre industriel par exemple c'est un
exemple de succès européen
mais c'est industrie est confronté un
ensemble unique de défis et c'est
pourquoi nous allons présenter
en train de mesures européennes sur
l'énergie éolienne en travaillant
étroitement avec l'industrie et les
États membres nous allons accélérer
encore davantage à délivrance des permis
nous allons améliorer le système
d'enchères dans l'Union européenne nous
allons mettre l'accent sur les
compétences l'accès aux financement et
la stabilité des chaînes de
provisionnement
mais l'autre vision et plus large ce
n'est pas un seul secteur de l'éolien à
l'acier les batteries au véhicules
électriques notre ambition est très
claire
l'avenir de notre industrie des
technologies propres doit se construire
en Europe c'est ça notre tâche
des choses
du pacte il va falloir nous gardons le
cap nous restons ambitieux nous ne
devions pas de notre stratégie de
croissance
et nous aurons toujours à cœur de
garantir une transition juste et
équitable
ça signifie garantir un résultat
équitable pour les générations futures
la possibilité d'habiter une planète
saine et garantir tous une transition
équitable avec des emplois décents et la
promesse solennelle ne laissait personne
de côté
simplement aux emplois dans le secteur
manufacturiers et à la compétitivité à
sujet dont on parle beaucoup ces
jours-ci notre industrie et nos
entreprises technologiques aiment la
concurrence
savent que la concurrence mondiale est
bonne pour les affaires et qu'elle crée
des emplois de qualité si en Europe
mais la concurrence
que si elle est équitable
trop souvent nos entreprises se trouvent
exclues de marché étrangers ils sont
victimes de comportement prédateurs
elles sont souvent battues sur le
terrain des prix par des concurrents
bénéficiant des normes subventions
publiques
nous n'avons pas oublié combien l'autre
industrie solaire avait bâti les
pratiques commerciales des loyales de la
Chine nombre de jeunes entreprises ont
été poussés hors du marché par des
concurrents chinois fortement
subventionnés les sociétés pionnières
ont dû déposer le bilan
des talents prometteurs sont partis
chercher fortune à l'étranger
c'est pourquoi
l'équité dans l'économie mondiale est si
importante
sur la vie des gens et le seul moyen de
subsistance des industries et des
communautés entières ont dépendent nous
devons donc être très lucide quand on
risque auquel nous sommes confrontés
c'est une industrie essentielle pour
l'économie propre avec un énorme
potentiel pour l'Europe
mais les marchés sont aujourd'hui
inondées de voitures électriques
chinoises bon marché
dans le prix et maintenu
artificiellement bas par la subventions
publiques massive
et de même que nous n'acceptons pas ces
distorsions sur notre marché de
l'acceptons pas venant de l'extérieur
je vous annonce donc aujourd'hui que la
Commission ouvre une enquête anti
subventions sur les véhicules
électriques en provenance de Chine
[Applaudissements]
nous devons nous défendre contre les
pratiques des voyages mais il est tout
essentiel de maintenir nos lignes de
communication ouverte et de poursuivre
notre dialogue avec la Chine parce qu'il
y a aussi des sujets sur lesquels nous
pouvons et devons coopérer
réduction des risques pas les couplage
ce sera mon approche envers les
dirigeants chinois
lors du sommet Chine qui tiendra plus
tard cette année
mesdames et messieurs les députés
dans l'Union européenne
nous sommes fiers de notre diversité
culturelle
nous sommes cette Europe des régions
riche d'une grande diversité en matière
de langue de musique d'art de tradition
d'artisanat et de gastronomie
nous sommes également l'Europe d'une
biodiversité unique
espèces vives uniquement en Europe
nulle part ailleurs au monde
dans le nord de l'Europe se trouve la
mer des Wadden inscrite au patrimoine
mondial de l'UNESCO c'est un habitat
unique qui abrite des espèces animales
et végétales rares et qui est essentiel
à la survie de millions d'oiseaux
migrateurs avec la mer Baltique nous
avons là la plus grande mère saumâtre du
monde au sud de se rejoindre des plaines
européennes anciennes et toujours
caractérisée par de grandes tourbières
et des zones humides
ces régions sont des alliés importants
dans la lutte contre les avancées du
changement climatique
les tourbières les ennemis de protéger
retiennent de grandes quantités de gaz à
effet de serre
préserve le cycles hydrologiques
régionaux et abrite une biodiversité
unique
et l'Europe est riche en forêt des
majestueuses forêts de conifères au nord
et à l'est ou encore les dernières
forêts primaires de chênes et de l'être
en Europe centrale jusqu'au forêt de
chaîne Liège du sud de l'Europe
toutes nous offre des biens et des
services irremplaçables elles absorbent
le carbone
elle procure du bois et d'autres
matériaux elles fertilisent les sols
filtres l'air et l'eau
la biodiversité et les services
écosystémiques sont essentiels à notre
survie à tous en Europe
la destruction de cette nature nous fait
perdre non seulement nos moyens de
subsistance mais aussi notre sentiment
d'appartenance
nous devons la préserver
[Applaudissements]
et dans le même temps nous devons nous
faire un devoir aujourd'hui à l'avenir
de sécuriser nos moyens de subsistance
au sein de la nature et en accord avec
la nature je tiens aujourd'hui à rendre
hommage à nos agriculteurs
[Applaudissements]
jour après jour notre approvisionnement
alimentaire garantir une alimentation
saine en Europe en Europe c'est là le
devoir de l'agriculture le fondement de
notre politique agricole et c'est aussi
garantir l'indépendance de notre
approvisionnement alimentaire c'est son
se garanties qu'offre nos agriculteurs
et cela ne va pas de soi car
nos agriculteurs sont soumis à l'impact
croissant sur leur travail sur le revenu
de l'agression russe contre l'Ukraine du
changement climatique les sécheresses
les incendies les inondations et aussi
les nouvelles obligations qui s'imposent
nous devons en tenir compte
beaucoup s'engagent déjà en faveur d'une
agriculture plus durable
nous devons relever ces nouveaux défis
aux côtés des agriculteurs et des
agricultrices ce n'est qu'un si que nous
pourrons garantir notre sécurité
alimentaire alimentaire pour l'avenir
également nous avons donc besoin de plus
de dialogues et de moins de polarisation
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
souhaitons engager un dialogue
stratégique sur l'avenir de
l'agriculture dans l'Union européenne
je suis et je demeure convaincu que
l'agriculture et la protection de la
nature peuvent aller de pair nous avons
besoin des deux
on a le même
et Messieurs une transition équitable
pour les agriculteurs les familles et
l'industrie c'est la marque de fabrique
de cette législature et c'est d'autant
plus important que nous faisons face à
des forts vont au contraire sur le plan
économique
je note 3 grands défis économiques pour
notre industrie dans l'année à venir
la pénurie de main d'oeuvre et de
compétences l'inflation
et la nécessité de faciliter l'activité
de nos entreprises
le premier de ces défis concerne le
marché de travail ne vont pas oublier
les premiers jours de la pandémie quand
tout le monde prédisait une nouvelle
vase de chômage de masse du genre de
celle qui s'est produit dans les années
1930 mais nous avons déjoué cette
prédiction grâce à la toute première
initiative européenne en matière de
chômage partiel nous avons sauvé 40
millions d'emplois c'est c'était et
c'est l'économie sociale de marché
européenne en action et nous pouvons en
être fiers
[Applaudissements]
nous avons ensuite immédiatement relancé
notre moteur économique grâce à next
generation et nous voyons les résultats
aujourd'hui l'Europe est proche du plein
emploi
ce ne sont pas des millions de personnes
qui recherchent un emploi mais des
millions d'emplois qui cherchent
preneurs
et de compétences atteignent des niveaux
au record ici et dans toutes les grandes
économies
74% des PME déclarent faire face à des
pénuries de compétences
précise au plus fort de la saison
touristique les restaurants et les bars
d'Europe fonctionne en horaire réduit
faute de pouvoir trouver du personnel
les hôpitaux reportent des traitements à
cause du manque d'infirmières et
d'infirmiers et deux tiers des
entreprises européennes cherchent de
spécialistes en informatique deux tiers
dans le même temps des millions de
parents essentiellement des mers
et vie familiale parce qu'ils ne
trouvent pas de solutions d'accueil pour
leurs enfants oui millions de jeunes
sont sans emploi et nous suivent ni
études ni formation 8 millions leur rêve
leur vie même sont en suspend en
veilleuse
cette situation est non seulement cause
de grandes souffrances personnelles pour
ces individus mais c'est aussi l'un des
principaux goulets d'étranglement de
notre compétitivité
parce que les pénuries de main d'oeuvre
entravent la capacité d'innover de se
développer de prospérer nous devons donc
améliorer l'accès au marché du travail
en particulier pour les jeunes pour les
femmes et nous avons besoin d'une
immigration de main d'oeuvre qualifiée
nous devons en outre apporter une
réponse
aux mutations technologiques sociétales
et démographique des mutations profondes
et pour ce faire nous devrions nous
appuyer sur l'expertise des entreprises
et des syndicats nos partenaires de
négociation collective
cela fait presque 40 ans
Jacques Delors
convoquait la réunion de Val Duchesse
qui a vu naître le dialogue social
européen
depuis lors les partenaires sociaux ont
façonné l'Union d'aujourd'hui assurant
progrès et prospérité à des millions de
personnes
alors que notre monde se transforme plus
vite que jamais les partenaires sociaux
doivent de nouveau être au coeur de
notre avenir ensemble nous devons nous
concentrer sur les défis auxquels le
marché du travail est confronté les
pénuries compétences et de main d'oeuvre
mais aussi des nouveaux défis liés à
l'IA et c'est pourquoi nous organiserons
l'an prochain avec la présidence belge
un nouveau sommet des partenaires
sociaux aval duchesse
l'avenir de l'Europe se construira avec
nos partenaires sociaux et par eux c'est
notre tâche
[Applaudissements]
c'est la persistance et l'inflation
forte Christine Lagarde et la Banque
centrale européenne travaille sans
relâche pour juguler une impression
a commencé à faire baisser le prix
d'énergie
nous n'avons pas oublié
que Poutine a délibérément utilisé le
gaz comme une arme ni oublier les
craintes d'une panne généralisée d'une
crise énergétique comme celle des années
beaucoup pensé que nous n'aurions pas
assez d'énergie pour traverser l'hiver
que nous avons mis en commun notre
demande et nos achats d'énergie dans le
même temps
contrairement aux années 70
nous nous sommes servis de la crise pour
investir massivement dans les énergies
renouvelables et accélérer la transition
propre nous avons mis un profil critique
de l'Europe pour faire baisser les prix
et sécuriser notre provisionnement le
prix du gaz en Europe dépasser 300 euros
par mégawatts heure il y a un an
35 euros
on est passé de 300 à 35
de réussite
le troisième défi
européennes et de leur faciliter
l'activité
les petites entreprises n'ont pas la
capacité d'affronter la complexité
administrative
par la longueur des procédures cela
signifie souvent
quels sont moins de choses avec le temps
qu'elle dispose et qu'elle aura des
occasions de se développer c'est
pourquoi
avant la fin
de lieu pour les PME placé sous mon
autorité directe
directement
quelles difficultés elle rencontre au
quotidien pour chaque nouveau texte
législatif nous procédons à un contrôle
de compétitivité confiant un comité
indépendant
le mois prochain nous présenterons les
premières propositions législatives
mises en réduire les obligations de
déclaration au niveau européen de 25%
[Applaudissements]
ont besoin de votre soutien car il
s'agit d'une entreprise que toutes les
institutions européennes doivent mener
collectivement nous devons également
travailler avec les États membres pour
que l'objectif de 25% de réduction soit
atteint aussi au niveau national
il me semble qu'il est temps de
faciliter l'activité des entreprises en
Europe
[Applaudissements]
pour innover et se développer et
fabriquer et il y va la souveraineté de
l'Europe comme les dirigeants
ensoleillés à Versailles
il est impératif pour l'économie et pour
la sécurité nationale le préserver un
avantage européen en ce qui concerne les
technologies critiques et émergentes
nécessite également un financement
européen commun
c'est la raison pour laquelle dans le
cadre de notre proposition de révision
du budget européen nous avons proposé de
créer la plateforme step
avec STEP nous pourrons stimuler
mobiliser orienter les fondues pour
investir dans tout ce qui va de la
microélectronique à l'informatique
quantique et à lire de la biotechnologie
à la technologie propre une entreprise
ont besoin de ce soutien maintenant je
m'appelle donc un accord rapide sur
notre profession de budget je sais que
je peux compter cette assemblée
[Musique]
et il y a d'autres choses encore qui
vont servir compétitivité
nous avons eu de véritables boules
d'étranglement dans les chaînes
provisionnements mondiales causer
notamment par les politiques des
librairies de certains pays prenez par
exemple la Chine et ses restrictions à
l'exportation de gallium et de germanium
de métaux essentiels
auditeurs les panneaux solaires ça
montre pourquoi il est important que
l'Europe renforce la sécurité économique
une réduction des risques par un
découplage et je suis très fier que ce
concept est recueilli un là je soutiens
parmi le partenaires clés de l'Australie
au Japon passant par les États-Unis et
de nombreuses autres pays du monde
veulent travailler ensemble
trop la seule fournisseur pour les
minerais critiques
d'autres on aime avec latine on
l'Afrique on souhaite développer juste
titre des industries locales
transformations
à l'étranger
cette année nous organiserons la
première réunion de notre club des
matières premières critiques dans le
même temps
ouvert et équitable à ce jour nous avons
conclu de nouveaux accords de
libre-échange que Chili la
Nouvelle-Zélande le Kenya nous devrions
nous affaires avec l'Australie le
Mexique et le Mercosur d'ici la fin
d'année et puis après l'un des Indonésie
le commerce intelligent créé des emplois
de qualité et de la prospérité
[Applaudissements]
se présente au moment où nous demandons
aussi un industrie que je joue un rôle
moteur dans la transition propre
plus loin
et voir comment nous resterons
compétitifs
c'est pourquoi j'ai demandé à Mario
Draghi
l'un des esprits européens les plus
brillants en matière économique
d'établir un rapport sur l'avenir de la
compétitivité européenne parce que
l'Europe sera tout pour conserver son
avantage concurrentiel quoi qu'il en
coûte
particuliers nous avons vu à quel point
la technologie numérique est importante
d'investissement de 20% dans les projets
numériques de Next Generation
pour numériser leur système de soins de
santé leur système judiciaire en réseau
de transport
des risques liés au monde
sur Internet avait été pensé comme un
instrument de partage des connaissances
que vous les esprits et créer des liens
entre les gens c'est toujours le cas
mais
des informations la diffusion de contenu
préjudiciaire les risques pour la
confidentialité de nos données
mais tout cela
a créé un manque de confiance et parfois
à des violations des droits fondamentaux
des personnes
des droits des citoyens dans le monde
numérique le DSA le DMA prêt un espace
numérique plus sûr dans lequel les
droits fondamentaux sont protégés et il
garantissent une équité en imposant des
imbrications précises au grandes
entreprises technologiques il s'agit
d'une avancée historique dont nous
devrions être fiers
et l'améliorera sans aucun doute les
soins de santé se mirera la productivité
revenir un changement climatique nous en
avons besoin
pas sous-estimer les menaces très
réelles qu'elle crée
devrait être une traitement mondiale
au même titre que d'autres risques
menaçant la société tout entière comme
les pandémies et la guerre nucléaire
qui est accessible puissante et
adaptable à de très nombreux
utilisations dans civils que militaires
et elle évolue plus rapidement que ces
concepteurs eux-mêmes de l'avaient prévu
il nous reste donc maintenant peu de
temps
orienter cette technologie de manière
responsable je pense que l'Europe en
collaboration ses partenaires devraient
ouvrir la voie un nouveau cadre mondial
broyeur reposant sur trois piliers des
garçons le gouvernance et l'orientation
de l'innovation
premièrement
d'une manière centrée sur l'humain
transparente responsable c'est pourquoi
une approche législative au cours des
100 premiers jours de mon mandat
nous avons présenté je vous rappelle
règlement sur lien la première
législation mondiale en la matière qui
est favorable à l'innovation
et je tiens à remercier le Parlement et
le Conseil pour le travail qu'ils ont
accompli sans relâche sur cette
législation novatrice notre législation
sur les a déjà un modèle pour le monde
entier nous devons maintenant
nous concentrer sur adopter ses règles
dès que possible et les mettre en œuvre
le deuxième pilier c'est la gouvernance
nous jetons aujourd'hui les bases d'un
système de gouvernance unique en Europe
mais nous devrions également fait le
concept nos partenaires pour voir tous
la même compréhension de l'impact de
lire dans nos sociétés
pensons par exemple à la contribution
inestimable du GIEC pour le climat
qui fournit les données scientifiques
les plus récentes au décideurs
politiques je pense que nous avons
besoin d'un organe similaire
et ses avantages pour
l'humanités technologique et des experts
indépendants nous pourrions
[Musique]
le troisième pilier consiste à orienter
l'innovation de manière responsable
ça va ça nous investissements ces
dernières années l'Europe et des emmène
à la pointe en matière de supercalcules
avec 3 des 5 supercalculateurs les plus
puissants du monde nous devons profiter
de cette
c'est pourquoi j'annonce aujourd'hui une
nouvelle initiative destinée à ouvrir
nos ordinateurs à haute performance aux
jeunes entreprises
mais ce n'est qu'une partie de notre
action mise en orientée d'innovation
ce qu'il nous faut c'est un dialogue
ouvert avec ceux qui développent et
déployés
ce dialogue il existe déjà aux
États-Unis vous le savez cette grande
entreprise technologiques ont déjà
accepté des règles volontaires en
matière de sûreté de sécurité et de
confiance
c'est le cas ici où nous collabrons avec
les entreprises diables pour qu'elles
s'engagent
volontairement
respecter les principes établis par
règlement solidaire avant son entrée en
vigueur
donc nous devons maintenant faire
converger toutes ces initiatives
afin d'adopter les normes mondiales
minimales pour une utilisation sur
éthique de lien
nos citoyens méritent
que si nous sommes unis à l'intérieur
personne ne nous divisera de l'extérieur
c'était le raisonnement qui soustendait
la commission géopolitique notre
approche Tim du rock nous a permis
d'être plus stratégique plus affirmé et
plus unie et c'est plus important que
jamais
devant les pertes dévastatrices en vie
humaine qu'on subit la Libye et le Maroc
à la suite des violents inondations et
du terrible tremblement de terre
l'Europe se tiendra toujours près à
apporter son soutien de quelques
manières que ce soit
il convient aussi de penser à la région
du Sahel lune des plus pauvres du monde
mais qui connaît une croissance
démographique extrêmement rapide la
succession des coups d'État militaire
augmentera l'instabilité dans la région
pour des années à venir
la Russie exerce une influence sur le
chaos qui règne et l'Empire également
profit la région est devenue interro
fertile pour le terrorisme
concernent directement l'Europe pour
notre sécurité pour notre prospérité
nous devons donc faire preuve de la même
unité d'intention à l'égard de l'Afrique
celle que nous avons montré pour le
crème c'est une obligation nous devons
nous concentrer sur la coopération avec
les gouvernements légitimes et les
organisations régionales il nous faut
développer un partenariat mutuellement
bénéfique axé sur des problématiques
communes à l'Europe et à l'Afrique
c'est pourquoi avec le haut représenté
représentants Borel nous travaillerons à
l'élaboration d'une nouvelle approche
stratégique qui conviendra de faire
avancer lors du prochain sommet UE ua
mesdames et messieurs les députés
l'histoire est en mouvement
la Russie même une guerre à grande
échelle contre les principes fondateurs
de la Charte des Nations Unies
dans les pays d'Asie central jusqu'à la
région un duo Indo-Pacifique
dans un monde sans loi et puisse finir
par subir le même sort que l'Ukraine oui
s'il y a nous observons de la part de
certains pays une tentative claire de
revenir à un système de logique de bloc
avec des pays qui s'isolent et qui
tentent d'en influencer d'autres
alors que nous voyons énormément
d'économies émergentes qui ressentent un
malaise plus profond quant à la manière
dont les institutions et la
mondialisation fonctionne pour elle ces
préoccupations sont légitimes
ces pays aux économies émergentes qui
ont pourra tout leur citoyens leurs
ressources naturelles sont des alliés
essentiels pour construire un monde plus
propre plus sûr plus prospère l'Europe
est collabora toujours avec ces pays
pour réformer et améliorer le système
international nous voulons jouer un rôle
central dans les efforts dép pour rendre
plus juste l'ordre fondé sur les règles
et pour une répartition plus équitable
cela impliquera également de collaborer
avec les nouveaux comme les anciens
partenaires pour approfondir nos
relations et ici avec la stratégie
globaldge l'offre de l'Europe est unique
la stratégie globalité est plus
transparente plus durable plus
attrayante sur le plan économique la
semaine dernière encore j'étais à New
Delhi et nous avons signé le projet je
crois le plus ambitieux de notre
génération
[Musique]
de Moyen-Orient Europe
directe à ce jour entre l'Inde le golf
arabique et l'Europe avec une liaison
ferroviaire qui permettra d'accélérer de
40% des échanges commerciaux entre l'un
et l'Europe une ligne inexplique à un
gazoduc d'hydrogène propre pour
permettre des échanges d'Internet
d'énergie propre
entre l'Asie le Moyen-Orient et l'Europe
et grâce à un câble de données à od
débit qui est relié à certains des
écosystèmes numériques les plus
innovants au monde en créant des
débouchés commerciaux tout au long de ce
corrida ces connexions sont à la pointe
de la technologie elles sont plus
rapides plus courtes et plus propres
c'est ce dont nous avons besoin
[Applaudissements]
en Amérique latine en Asie du Sud-Est en
Afrique que ça soit pour créer une
économie de l'hydrogène locale
avec les Philippines ce sont des
investissements dans les économies de
nos partenaires autrement dit des
investissements dans la prospérité la
sécurité de l'Europe alors que le monde
change rapidement
chaque jour les conflits
le changement climatique et
l'instabilité
pousse les populations à chercher refuge
ailleurs
j'ai toujours eu la ferme conviction que
la migration doit être gérée
cela nécessite de la patience
des efforts de longue durée avec nos
partenaires
et surtout de l'unité au sein de notre
union
et c'est l'esprit du nouveau pacte sur
la migration et la ville
lorsque j'ai pris mes fonctions
il ne semblait pas y avoir des compromis
possibles en vue
mais avec le pacte nous avons trouvé un
nouvel équilibre
entre la protection des frontières et la
protection des personnes
entre souveraineté
et solidarité
entre sécurité
et humanité
nous avons écouté à tous les États
membres nous nous sommes penchés sur
toutes les routes migratoires et nous
avons traduit l'esprit du pacte en
solution pratique
nous avons réagi rapidement et de
manière unie à l'attaque hybride de la
Biélorussie
nous avons travaillé en étroite
collaboration avec nos partenaires des
Balkans occidentaux et réduit les flux
migratoires
nous avons signé avec la Tunisie en
Tunisie un partenariat qui apporte des
avantages mutuels au-delà de la
migration de l'éducation et compétences
professionnelles à l'énergie et la
sécurité
et nous voulons maintenir maintenant
travailler sur des accords similaires
avec d'autres pays nous avons renforcé
la protection des frontières
les agents européennes ont augmenté leur
coopération avec les États membres
et je veux remercier en particulier la
Bulgarie et la Roumanie d'avoir montré
la voix en mettant en avant les bonnes
pratiques en matière d'asile et de
retour et elles ont prouvé la Bulgarie
et la Roumanie font partie de notre
espace Schengen laissant les enfants
entrer sans plus de retard
mesdames et messieurs notre travail sur
la migration se fondent sur la
conviction que l'unité est à notre
portée
un accord sur le pacte n'a jamais été
aussi proche
le Parlement et le Conseil ont une
occasion historique de le faire aboutir
montrons que l'Europe peut gérer
l'immigration avec efficacité et
compassion finissons le travail
[Applaudissements]
nous savons que la migration exige un
travail constant et que celui-ci n'est
jamais aussi vital que dans la lutte
contre les passeurs les passeurs
attirent des personnes désespérées avec
leur mensonges et les entraînent sur des
routes mortelles à travers le désert ou
sur des bateaux un propre à la
navigation en mer la manière dont ces
passeurs opère évolue sans cesse mais
notre législation a plus de 20 ans et
doit être modernisé urgence nous avons
donc besoin d'une nouvelle législation
et de nouvelles structure de gouvernance
nous avons besoin d'une application plus
stricte de la loi de poursuites
judiciaire et d'un rôle plus important
pour nos agences Europole
nous devons travailler avec nos
partenaires pour lutter contre ce fléau
mondial qu'elle atteinte des êtres
humains et c'est pourquoi la Commission
organisera une conférence internationale
sur la lutte contre la traite des êtres
humains il est temps de mettre un terme
à ce commerce criminel audio
mesdames et messieurs les députés
le jour où les chars russes ont franchi
la frontière et sont entrés en Ukraine
une jeune mère ukrainienne est partie
pour Prague afin d'y mettre son enfance
sécurité
a apposé le cachet sur son passeport
elle a éclaté en sanglot
son fils n'a pas compris ce qu'il se
passait
il a demandé à sa mère pourquoi elle
pleurait
et elle a répondu parce que nous sommes
chez nous
expliquer c'est nous sommes en Europe
ce jour-là cette mère ukrainienne a eu
le sentiment que l'Europe c'était chez
elle
parce qu'un foyer c'est l'endroit où
règne de la confiance mutuelle maladie
et les Ukrainiens ont pu faire confiance
à leur concitoyens heureux
Victoria à Mélina
de la jeune génération et c'était aussi
une infatigable militante en faveur de
la justice
après avoir mis son fils en sécurité
Victoria est retourné en Ukraine pour
documenter les crimes de guerre
perpétrées par la Russie un an plus tard
elle a été tuée par un missile
balistique russe alors qu'elle dînait
avec des collègues écrivains
de guerre russe
l'une des innombrables attaques visant
des civils innocents ce soir là Victoria
Mélina se trouve avec trois amis parmi
lesquels Hector Abad également écrivain
d'origine colombienne
créé pour informer la population
latino-américaine de la guerre
d'agression menée par la Russie et des
attaques contre les civils
serait lui-même la cible des attaques
russes
qui ne comprenait pas pourquoi lui était
en vie alors que Victoria était morte
mais aujourd'hui Hector raconte au monde
l'histoire de Victoria afin que personne
n'oublie Victoria et pour mettre fin à
cette guerre je suis honoré que Hector
soit présent parmi nous aujourd'hui et
je veux que vous sachiez que je vous
remercie docteur je veux vous remercier
je veux que vous sachiez que nous allons
préserver vivant le souvenir de Victoria
et de toutes les autres victimes aguanta
[Applaudissements]
nous serons aux côtés de l'Ukraine tout
au long du chemin aussi longtemps que
nécessaire depuis le début de la guerre
4 millions du Kenya ont trouvé refuge
dans notre union
et je tiens à leur dire que
ils sont aujourd'hui toujours les
bienvenus tout comme pendant les
terribles première semaine de la guerre
nous avons fait en sorte qu'ils aient un
accès à un logement à des soins de santé
au marché du travail et bien plus encore
mesdames et messieurs les députés c'est
ainsi que l'Europe a répondu à l'appel
de l'histoire
je suis de leur fier d'annoncer que la
Commission proposera d'étendre notre
protection temporaire aux Ukrainiens
dans l'Union européenne notre soutien à
l'Ukraine perdurera
oui
nous avons fourni 12 milliards d'euros
rien que cette année pour contribuer au
paiement des salaires et des pensions
pour aider les hôpitaux les écoles les
autres services à fonctionner et grâce à
notre proposition à sac nous
intensifions la production de munitions
afin de contribuer à répondre aux
besoins immédiats de l'Ukraine mais nous
nous tournons également vers l'avenir
et c'est pourquoi nous avons proposé 50
milliards d'euros supplémentaires sur
quatre ans pour investir et pour
réformer
nous sommes contribuera à bâtir l'avenir
de l'Ukraine afin de reconstruire un
pays moderne et prospère cet avenir est
tout à fait clair
ce Parlement la déclaré au effort
l'avenir de l'Ukraine se trouve dans
notre union l'avenir des Balkans
occidentaux se trouve dans notre union
l'avenir de la Moldavie se trouve dans
notre union
[Applaudissements]
et je sais à quel point la perspective
européenne est importante pourtant de
gens en Géorgie
mesdames et messieurs les députés j'ai
commencé par parler de l'Europe en
disant qu'elle avait répondu à l'appel
de l'histoire
et l'histoire nous appelle désormais à
œuvré afin de compléter notre union
dans un monde où certains tentent
d'opérer une sélection entre les
différents pays nous ne pouvons pas nous
permettre de laisser de côté nos
concitoyens européens dans un monde où
la taille et le poids sont importants il
est clairement dans l'intérêt
stratégique et sécuritaire de l'Europe
de compléter notre union au delà de cet
environnement politique et géopolitique
nous devons bien voir quels sont les
enjeux réels nous devons définir une
vision pour mener à bien notre
élargissement
une union complète peuplée de plus de
500 millions d'habitants vivant dans une
union libre démocratique et prospère une
union complète dont le jeune citoyens
peuvent en toute liberté vivre étudier
et travailler une union complète
composée de dém ocratie dynamiques dans
lesquelles les juges sont indépendants
les oppositions respectées et les
journalistes protégés parce que l'État
de droit et les droits fondamentaux
formeront toujours
le socle de notre union dans les États
membres actuels comme futur
c'est pourquoi la Commission a fait des
rapports annuels sur l'état de droit une
priorité essentielle nous travaillons
étroitement avec les États membres pour
recenser les progrès les sujets de
préoccupation et pour formuler les
recommandations d'avenir cela a garantit
la réédition de compte devant ce
Parlement devant les parlements
nationaux cela a permis un dialogue
entre les États membres et cette
approche produit des résultats
je pense
nous pourrons faire de même pour les
futurs États membres et c'est pourquoi
je suis très heureuse d'annoncer que
nous allons ouvrir les rapports sur
l'état de droit au pays en voie
d'adhésion qui se mobilise pour
accélérer encore le processus
cela les mettra sur un pied d'égalité
avec les États membres et cela les
soutiendra dans leurs efforts de réforme
cela contribuera à inscrire dans
l'avenir une
union de la liberté des droits et des
valeurs pour tous
[Applaudissements]
les députés et non pas les États membres
prochaine phrase et il s'agit de notre
intérêt commun le Parlement des États
membres et la Commission tous ensemble
ce jour-là nous l'avions baptisé la
Journée européenne de bienvenue
c'était un triomphe de détermination et
d'espoir sur le poids du passé et au
cours des 20 années qui ont suivi nous
avons vécu une réussite économique qui
améliorait la vie de millions de
personnes
je souhaite que nous nous préparions
avec enthousiasme au vu de la prochaine
journée européenne de bienvenue au
prochain succès économique je sais que
le chemin ne sera pas sans obstacle
l'adhésion est un processus fondé sur le
mérite et la commission défendra
toujours ce principe cela exige beaucoup
de travail et d'esprit de leadership
mais il existe déjà de nombreux progrès
nous avons vu les grandes avancées
réalisées par l'Ukraine depuis que nous
lui avons accordé le statut de pays
candidats et nous avons vu la
détermination d'autres pays candidats à
se réformer
mesdames et messieurs les députés il est
temps à présent de nous élever à la
hauteur de cette détermination cela
signifie qu'il faut réfléchir à la
manière dont nous devons nous préparer
pour former une union complète dépasser
les vieux débats simples sur
l'élargissement il ne s'agit pas de
choisir entre approfondir l'intégration
ou élargir l'Union nous pouvons nous
devons faire l'aide pour nous donner le
poids géopolitique et les capacités
nécessaires pour agir c'est ce que notre
union a toujours fait chaque vague
d'élargissement s'est accompagnée d'un
approfondissement politique nous sommes
passés du charbon et de l'acier à une
intégration économique complète
et après la chute du rideau de fer nous
avons transformé un projet économique en
une véritable union des peuples et des
états
[Musique]
élargissement doit également être un
catalyseur de progrès
nous avons commencé à construire une
union de la santé à 27
et je suis convaincue que nous pouvons
la parachever à 30 voire plus nous avons
commencé à construire une union de la
défense à 27 et je suis convaincu que
nous pouvons la parachever à 30 voir
plus nous avons prouvé que nous pouvons
être une union géopolitique et que nous
pouvons avancer rapidement lorsque nous
sommes unis et je suis convaincue que
l'équipe Europe fonctionnera également à
plus de 30 membres
mesdames et messieurs les députés je
sais que cette assemblée pense de même
le Parlement européen a toujours été
l'un des principaux moteurs de
l'intégration européenne
il est depuis des décennies
et il est à nouveau aujourd'hui
je soutiendrai toujours ce Parlement
ainsi que tous ceux qui veulent réformer
l'Union européenne afin de la rendre
plus efficace pour ses citoyens et oui
cela passera par l'organisation d'une
convention européenne et par une
modification des traités si et lorsque
cela sera nécessaire
[Applaudissements]
mais nous ne pouvons pas nous ne
devrions pas attendre de modifier les
traités pour avancer sur la voie de
l'élargissement nous pouvons adapter
plus rapidement que cela notre union en
vue de son élargissement autrement dit
répondre à des questions concrètes sur
le fonctionnement pratique d'une union à
plus de 30 pays et en particulier sur
notre capacité d'action la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'à chaque élargissement
nous avons donné tort à ceux qui
déclaraient que nous en serions moins
efficace
voyez les dernières années nous nous
sommes accordés sur Next Generation Ayu
à 27 nous nous sommes accordés sur
l'achat de vaccins à 27 nous nous sommes
accordés sur les sanctions on entend
record également à 27 nous sommes
accordés sur l'achat de gaz naturel non
seulement à 27 mais aussi avec l'Ukraine
la Moldavie et la Serbie c'est donc
possible
mais nous devons examiner de plus près
nos politiques une par une et comprendre
comment chacune serait impactée par
l'élargissement de l'Union
et c'est pourquoi la Commission
commencera à travailler sur une série de
réexamens de
élargissement des politiques pour voir
comment nous adapter à un élargissement
de l'Union nous devons réfléchir à la
façon dont nos institutions
travailleront le Parlement la commission
nous devons réfléchir à l'avenir de
notre budget
à ce qu'il finance quant à la façon dont
il le finance et à la manière dont il
est financé et nous devons comprendre
comment garantir des engagements
crédibles en matière de sécurité dans un
monde où la dissuasion est plus
importante que jamais ce sont des
questions que nous devons aborder
aujourd'hui si nous voulons être prêts
pour demain
et la commission jouera son rôle c'est
pourquoi nous présenterons nos idées
au débat des dirigeants de l'UE sous la
présidence belge
nous serons motivés par la conviction
que l'achèvement de notre union est le
meilleur investissement possible pour la
paix la sécurité et la prospérité sur
notre continent
il est donc temps pour notre Europe de
voir grand et d'écrire son propre destin
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs les députés
de notre devoir collectif d'écrire une
nouvelle histoire pour l'Europe
se trouve aujourd'hui l'histoire
l'avenir de notre continent dépend des
choix que nous faisons aujourd'hui des
mesures que nous prenons pour compléter
notre union les Européens attendent de
l'Union qu'elle les défend dans cette
époque de concurrence entre grandes
puissances mais ils attendent aussi
qu'elle les protège et se tiennent à
leur côté comme un partenaire un allié
dans leur combat quotidien et nous
serons à l'écoute de leurs attentes si
c'est important pour les Européens c'est
important pour l'Europe
rappelons-nous la vision et les attentes
l'imagination de la jeune génération que
j'évoquais au début de mon discours le
moment est venu de lui montrer que nous
sommes capables de construire un
continent où vous pouvez être qui vous
êtes et mais qui vous voulez et vous
fixez autant d'objectifs que vous le
souhaitez en continuant qui est
réconcilié avec la nature et ouvre la
voie aux nouvelles technologies en
continent unis dans la liberté et dans
la paix une fois encore
le moment est venu pour l'Europe de
répondre à l'appel de l'histoire vive
l'Europe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
beaucoup merci madame la présidente
Madame Van berlaian je vous propose à
présent que nous entendions les
premières réactions des représentants
des groupes politiques a commencé par
Manfred Weber pour le PPE
est forte voilà donc grâce à votre
leadership et grâce à la coopération
avec le Parlement européen ensemble vous
l'avez dit très justement nous avons
pris ces dernières années les bonnes
décisions
les vaccins par exemple ne pas créer des
citoyens de première de deuxième classe
le fond de relance une idée la décision
de faire de l'Europe un pionnier en
matière de changement climatique la
décision de cesser de financer les États
membres dès lors que l'État de droit
n'est pas respecté une bonne idée les
sanctions contre la Russie la décision
de soutenir l'Ukraine et son adhésion à
l'Union européenne encore une bonne idée
nous sommes plus forts ensemble voilà le
message que nous adressons citoyennes et
citoyens européens chérie Ratchet
Stéphane j'aimerais également vous
remercier parce que nous avons pu
coopérer au cours de cette période
difficile le moteur politique de l'Union
européenne fonctionne la majorité Vander
laenne a permis c'est réalisations
d'être concrètes pour nous l'Europe et
le foyer des peuples nous voulons tenir
nos promesses pour chacune et chacun de
ces personnes sur le côté de la route
nous devons s'entendre les
préoccupations des uns et des autres et
non pas nous ériger en donneur de leçons
nous devons souder nos sociétés et non
pas créer des clivages j'aimerais
évoquer trois priorités du PPE la
première cette semaine la Commission
européenne a revu à la baisse et
perspectives économiques la façon de
plein fouet l'ensemble des pays de
l'Union européenne et les plus pauvres
sont les premières victimes c'est la
grande préoccupation du moment il faut
des écoles il faut des emplois des
revenus décents la prospérité nous en
avons besoin tout comme une industrie
forte et voilà pourquoi la proposition
que vous faites de réduire le fardeau
administratif avec
bilan de compétitivité est une bonne
idée le moratoire qui doit permettre de
conclure de nouveaux accords commerciaux
et notamment dans le domaine de
l'industrie c'est une bonne idée
également la compétitivité doit être une
priorité pour nous toutes et voilà
pourquoi je tiens à vous adresser mes
remerciements merci d'avoir invité Mario
Draghi voilà présenté de nouvelles idées
en la matière et puis nous saluons
également cette nouvelle phase du pacte
vert que les choses soient claires nous
le PPE nous avons soutenu 32 dossiers
pacte vert sur 34 l'idée fondamentale du
pacte vert nous la soutenons vis-à-vis
des générations à venir il faut que nous
tenions nos promesses mais s'il faut
également que nous entendions les
agriculteurs les PME les travailleurs
les jeunes et que nous produisons
davantage de denrées alimentaires et non
pas moins c'est là la réponse que nous
devons s'apporter nous devons réduire le
prix des denrées alimentaires et
l'inflation le PPE est le Parti du
Peuple et nous sommes prêts du peuple
des zones rurales
[Applaudissements]
il faut en effet que nous soyons à la
tête du mouvement qui nous permettra de
d'être une Europe exemple de CO2 nous ne
pouvons pas avoir un monde à la chinoise
nous ne voulons pas que des véhicules
électriques chinois profitent de nos
objectifs ambitieux en matière de climat
une fois que nous pensions davantage à
la nécessité de mener des activités
commerciales il ne faut pas ajouter des
interdictions à d'autres interdictions
pour les entreprises il faut des emplois
pour les européennes et les Européens il
faut que nous soyons plus fort ou plus
ferme dès lors qu'il s'agit des
négociations commerciales plus ferme
parce qu'il faut que nous activions
notre instrument dans le domaine de la
défense
face aux attaques panneaux solaires de
la Chine vous l'avez dit hier très
justement et puis il faut que nous
soyons plus fort dans le domaine
commercial afin que nous doutions d'une
union de démocratie basée sur le
commerce l'Australie l'Inde le Mercosur
sont autant de partenaires commerciaux
avec lesquels nous souhaitons partager
les mêmes valeurs puisque les sont à nos
yeux indissociables chers amis
renforçons notre union de l'innovation
veillons à ce que les plus grands
esprits travaillent ensemble afin de
vrai pour l'innovation dans le domaine
de la recherche contre le cancer ou de
l'intelligence artificielle deuxième
priorité pour le PPE l'immigration
l'Europe d'aujourd'hui se fait ici de
pouvoir accueillir de si nombreux
réfugiés jamais nous n'en avons
accueilli autant dans notre histoire
regardez ce que nous faisons pour
l'Ukraine et les Ukrainiens nous les
protégeons c'est dans l'ADN même de
l'Union européenne mais ça nous
frontière extérieurs nous devons pouvoir
décider de qui invocation entrer sur
notre territoire et qui n'a pas vocation
ayant entrer ça n'est pas au passeur
dans décider c'est à nous dans les idées
et l'Union européenne c'est un exemple
de coopération avec nos voisins qui
permettent de relever les défis comme
nous l'avons fait d'ailleurs par le
passé avec la Turquie il faut que nous
finalisions également le pacte pour
l'immigration c'est une occasion unique
dans notre histoire qui nous permettra
d'apporter une réponse adéquate au défi
le moment est venu de compter sur la
majorité fun darlyenne pour y parvenir
et puis troisième élément que je
souhaitais évoquer celui de l'avenir du
projet européen il y a de cela 25 ans
est né l'euro beaucoup l'ont Critiqué
Elodie avait une vision toutefois pour
l'Europe
une vision pour l'Euro et bien quel est
ce projet aujourd'hui ce projet européen
tout d'abord c'est un projet dans lequel
l'Ukraine l'emporte dans le conflit armé
dans lequel l'Ukraine sera intégré la
famille européenne dans une approche
basée sur les mérites l'Ukraine mais
également la Moldavie et les Balkans les
projets sont réels il faut aller plus
loin automatique de gaz il faut que nous
fassions s'en sortent de garantir notre
avenir
en 1954 non évoqué la communauté de la
défense et cela a été rejeté certains
ont fondu en l'arme c'était de Gasperi
mais revenons à cette idée de gaspérité
qui souhaitait une union de la défense
les commissaires peut veiller la
Commission peut veiller à ce que nous
unissions nos forces dans les airs sur
les terres dans les mers afin que nous
en fassions un véritable pilier de
l'Union européenne ça c'est un projet
c'est le projet de notre génération
cette défense européenne il faut
également que nous ayons une union c'est
la meilleure façon de lutter contre les
extrémistes ça n'est pas la peur la
colère ou même la haine qui doit
justifier l'éleval l'optimisme la vision
les valeurs et la volonté de franchir
les prochaines étapes voilà qui doit
guider les efforts de l'Union européenne
pour l'avenir et on commence aujourd'hui
Garcia Peres pour prendre la parole
donnons des socialistes et démocrates
vous avez madame 5 minutes
merci
nous assistons au dernier débat dans
l'Union et se déroule un moment de
changement en profondeur madame la
Présidente
merci merci pour votre capacité dialogue
pour aboutir à des consensus
les socialistes démocrates sont très
fiers d'avoir contribué d'avoir
mener des décisions historiques qui ont
remis l'Europe au cœur de la citoyenneté
contrairement la réponse donnée à la
crise financière 2008
frappée par le manque de coordination et
l'austérité imposé par la droite la
réponse à la pandémie et la guerre de la
Russie contre l'Ukraine dirigée par la
social démocratie ces caractérisé par
l'unité par la solidarité maintenant
notre première priorité doit être de
mettre en oeuvre la réindustrialisation
pour garantir l'autonomie et stratégique
ouverte
en pensant aussi à l'Afrique l'Amérique
latine un bac cette réelle
industrialisation nous devons également
progresser dans la transition écologique
ralentir les effets de changement
climatique c'est une obligation légale
mais aussi morale
la réforme du marché électrique pour
accélérer le déploiement des énergies
renouvelables réduire le prix de
l'électricité
climatique il est essentiel de briser le
silence maintenant avec un message
d'appui clair au pacte vert en mettant
en oeuvre également les lois sur la
restauration de la nature à la qualité
de l'air nous allons accorder beaucoup
d'attention
à la concrétisation de ces promesses
[Applaudissements]
mais pour créer de la richesse aussi de
nouvelles opportunités nous devons
renforcer le pilier social et là madame
j'aurais aimé entendre plus d'engagement
de votre part l'inflation les taux
d'intérêts élevés l'augmentation des
prêts hypothécaires ne favorise pas un
projet de vie juste le logement public
comme droit et pas combien de
spéculation la parité dans le domaine de
l'emploi l'interdiction des pratiques
non rémunérées retenu vital minimum une
stratégie anti pauvreté avec des
objectifs contraignants tout cela doit
se transformer en réalité
[Applaudissements]
je suis d'accord avec ce que vous avez
dit non ça veut dire non et maintenant
le moment est venu d'aller plus loin et
d'inclure à la violence contre les
femmes dans la liste des délits de
l'Union européenne
[Applaudissements]
parce que la cohésion sociale ça permet
aux personnes d'avoir dit digne mais ça
permet aussi d'agir avec une voix forte
avec un poids dans le monde maintenant
nous sommes une face à la graisseur
Poutine ta criminel qui finira séjour de
voir un tribunal international et la
commission sans plus tarder doit
présenter une proposition pour investir
les actifs russes gelés dans la
reconstruction de l'Ukraine nous sommes
unis mais il ne faut pas le reposer sur
nos lauriers le moment est venu de
renforcer l'unité l'Union européenne il
faut faciliter le processus de prise de
décision avec la majorité qualifiée nous
devons aussi continuer à soutenir des
pays de notre voisinage qui veulent
avoir un destin au sein de l'Union
européenne et alors que nous faisons
face à ces grands défis nous devons
trouver une solution à d'autres défis
qui ont marqué l'avenir de l'Union
européenne le pacte migration d'asile
pour éviter qu'on perd plus de vie
humaine en Méditerranée et mettez-moi
ici de dire une chose mais derrière
l'argent du contribuable européen il ne
peut pas se retrouver dans les poches de
gouvernement qui s'entraînent au droit
fondamentaux des personnes
[Applaudissements]
une capacité fiscale permanente pour
faire face aux futures crises la réforme
des règles fiscales une conduite sociale
c'est indispensable il faut une économie
plus compétitive mais ça ne suffit pas
cette croissance économique doit
également se traduire dans une meilleure
qualité de vie pour les personnes il
faut répartir les bénéfices à tous et
pas juste privilégié certains nous
vivons mesdames et messieurs dans une
Union européenne un projet de vie qui a
bâti le meilleur lieu pour la démocratie
les droits à la solidarité et l'égalité
et aujourd'hui l'alliance sur la droite
et l'extrême droite
c'est un risque d'échec énorme monsieur
Weber en politique il faut être cohérent
et être cohérent ça veut dire que il
faut que les paroles soient cohérentes
par rapport aux actes vous pouvez pas
faire appel à la majorité puis après
voter avec l'extrême droite pour former
des gouvernements ou des majorités dans
ce Parlement ça ça ne peut pas être fait
ce n'est possible
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on ne fera pas marche arrière nous
continuerons à bâtir une union prospère
ouverte d'intégration en union fière de
sa pluralité est à diversité et une
union qui embrasse l'étaler le droit qui
lutte pour la lutte pour l'égalité et la
justice sociale et quoi de changement
climatique on a toujours la possibilité
de réveiller 60 en l'Union européenne
rêvait d'un destin meilleur et elle en a
fait une réalité et maintenant nous
vivons ce rêve continuons à traduire ce
rêve en réalité merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à présent la parole à son président
Stéphane séjourné vous avez 4 minutes
c'est journée
merci madame la présidente madame la
Présidente chers collègues cette session
plénière sur l'état de l'Union n'est pas
comme les autres c'est la dernière de la
mandature c'est la dernière avant les
élections européennes vous l'avez dit
madame la Présidente c'est 4 dernières
années ont été parmi les plus marquantes
de l'histoire récente de la construction
européenne et réunion Europe est fière
d'avoir été en responsabilité pendant
cette période il n'y aura et fier
d'avoir été
utile au sein d'une coalition qui
n'était pas évidente mais qui a
rassemblé les pros européens de bonne
volonté je voudrais également remercier
les groupes qui ont travaillé à des
majorités des fois différentes à droite
et à gauche des fois coordonnées en
format vanne à l'arrière avec les
critiques qui a formulé ma collègue mais
nous avons réussi à avancer
avancer encore des nations avancer pour
l'Europe et si je veux résumer l'état
d'esprit de mon groupe nous sommes fiers
du bilan commun nous souhaitons que ces
derniers mois soient utiles à l'image de
ces quatre dernières années mes réunions
Europe est aussi lucide sur certaines
priorités et certaines priorités de mon
groupe nous n'y sommes pas encore j'y
reviendrai à la fin de mon intervention
madame la Présidente si je commence par
les éléments positifs je considère que
l'Europe a été utile à nos concitoyens
plus que jamais dans cette période elle
a été là dans la pandémie elle a été la
face à l'agression russe en Ukraine pour
unir les Européens l'Europe est là pour
les générations futures le Green Deal
fait de l'Europe le continent le plus
exemplaire en matière de transition
écologique nous n'avons pas avoir
l'écologie honteuse je ne connais aucune
autre chambre parlementaire dans le
monde qui a pris des décisions aussi
courageuses qu'elle nous avons pris ces
quatre dernières années sur ce sujet
nous sommes là
nous sommes là pour nos travailleurs nos
entreprises la réindustrialisation du
continent et désormais une réalité
enclenchée au nom de notre souveraineté
de nos emplois du pouvoir d'achat nous
sommes là pour chacun de nos concitoyens
sur leurs droits le Far West numérique
et désormais réguler par des lois
européennes l'indépendance de nos médias
sera bientôt garantie par une
législation spécifique nous sommes là
pour la sécurité collective et le
fondement d'une défense commune et
surtout ces sujets nous irons jusqu'au
bout je pense notamment au Green Deal si
je continue sur ce qui nous reste à
faire vous l'avez dit également madame
la Présidente Présidente il faut trouver
une solution durable pour les questions
migratoires cela fait partie des textes
que nous devons finaliser avec le paquet
énergie avec une réponse industrielle
européenne
c'est des neuf derniers mois je le
répète devront être utiles et sur un
autre domaine je me félicite que vous
ayez également entendu mon groupe être
utile ne veut pas dire réguler pour
réguler nous devons réduire la
bureaucratie sur nos citoyens sur nos
entrepreneurs être utile c'est aussi
investir à la hauteur de nos objectifs
les transitions vertes et digitales ne
seront réussies que si nos lois sont
simples intelligibles et financé madame
la Présidente pour terminer un sujet qui
fâche mon groupe vous le savez nous
sommes
déterminés à défendre le modèle
démocratique
je mesure le travail qui a été fait par
nos commissaires je me tourne également
sur les représentants du conseil en tant
que collégislateur nous avons vu que des
fois ça traînait des pieds du côté des
chefs d'État et de gouvernement l'Europe
ne répond pas encore aux appels
désespérés des juges polonais et
hongrois de la presse indépendante de la
société civile je reste sidéré quand des
procureurs italiens changent des états
civils d'enfants et donc retire des
droits à des mers parce qu'elles sont
lesbiennes
mon groupe appelle toujours toujours à
toujours plus d'efficacité toujours plus
de simplicité toujours plus de réforme
nous savons que l'unanimité est un
poison rendez-vous compte l'ampleur de
notre soutien ukrainien dépend
aujourd'hui de Victor Hormann notre
solidarité commune madame la Présidente
nous refusons le basculement de l'Europe
nous refusons l'urbanisation de notre
continent c'est un réel danger pas
seulement sur le plan de vue politique
mais aussi sur le point de vue
économique et social le risque de
corruption endémique le risque de voir
des communautés prises pour cibles
le contraire de notre ADN européen en
somme je dirais même le contraire de
notre projet civilisationnel pour notre
Europe madame la Présidente vous vouliez
une commission géopolitique vous avez
évoqué dans votre discours
elle a été par le Greg l'histoire bien
plus que cela mais attention les
démocraties meurent rarement des menaces
extérieures elle meurt souvent des
menaces intérieures à nous démocrates
d'agir à temps merci pour votre discours
nous partageons l'essentiel et que c'est
9 prochains mois soit utile merci
[Applaudissements]
vous avez six minutes
que je suis ici je participe à mon
dernier discours sur modèle débat sur
14 ans
aveuglée par l'orthodoxie économique et
sourde à l'urgence climatique éventuelle
mais maintenant les choses changent pour
la première fois de l'histoire l'Union
européenne
a fait de être sur d'autres climatique
une véritable et contre toute attente
surprise ceux qui n'ont jamais adhéré au
Green Deal avec l'âme aujourd'hui une
pause à moratoire afin d'affaiblir son
ambition et de protéger soi-disant notre
compétitivité mais vous comprenez ce que
je veux dire à eux je dis ceci nous ne
sommes pas au dessus de la nature
l'humanité fait partie de la nature
que nous le voulions ou non il y a des
limites à ce que notre planète peut
supporter et à ce qu'elle peut donner le
respect de ses limites ce n'est pas le
cheval de bataille des Verts c'est une
question de survie
et cette lutte pour la survie de trop
nombreux citoyens européens sont
aujourd'hui les témoins directs
pouvez-vous imaginer un pompier grec
s'éloignant d'un brasier qui fait rage
ou un secouriste l'organisation Slovénie
disons alors arrêtons là faisons une
pause non il donne tout ce qu'ils ont
pour maîtriser ces phénomènes
climatiques nous leur de vos à eux à
tous les citoyens victimes des extrêmes
déclenchés par changement climatique
d'agir avec tout ce que nous avons nous
avons attendu trop longtemps alors tenez
bon voilà la présidente une pompe à nous
contenter de mettre en oeuvre ce qui a
déjà été décidé et qu’un soit ne
signifie pas ne suffit pas à tel
objectif d'un réchauffement de 1,5
degrés et notre objectif il reste tant à
faire
au lieu d'être depuis de carbone notre
agriculture notre sylviculture sont
devenus des émetteurs nets de carbone
notre Terre notre eau et notre ère sont
tellement pollué par les produits
chimiques les métaux lourds les
particules fines et les plastiques
décès des maladies allant à l'échelle il
en résulte un effondrement de la
biodiversité et qui met en vie
en péril nos vies le moyen de
subsistance mais la transition
écologique n'est pas seulement une
nécessité c'est aussi la plus grande
opportunité économique pour l'Europe la
fille ferait de nous des suiveurs des
laissés pour compte condamner apporter
du reste du monde les solutions nous
avons besoin la clé de la compétitivité
chers collègues et que nos économies
adoptent la transformation vers
soutiennent les entrepreneurs qui
veulent la mener et se débarrassent des
chercheurs de rente c'est la voix la
plus sûre de la prospérité de lieu
dépendra cependant de notre capacité à
demander plus à ceux qui ont le plus et
moins à ceux qui ont le moins car s'il y
a des limites à ce que nous vous pouvons
faire subir à la planète il y en a tout
autant aux injustices que nos sociétés
peuvent tolérer
crise financière crise de l'euro
pandémie guerre en Ukraine crise
énergétique se sont à chaque fois les
citoyens ordinaires qui passent à la
caisse pendant que les détenteurs de
capitaux accumulent sans relâche même
Christine gay Lagarde le dit le gros de
l'inflation actuelle est dû au
gonflement abject mon adjectif des
profits des grandes entreprises vous
mobectorez sans doute madame la
Présidente que les grands leviers de la
justice sociale et fiscale sont du
ressort des États membres et c'est vrai
mais si par le passé la Commission
européenne a supposer nos gouvernements
adopté des réformes injustes elle peut
tout autant aujourd'hui les inciter à
faire ce qui est juste
elle dit pause elle dispose moins de
moyens d'action direct prenons qu'à du
logement la plupart des jeunes ne savent
plus se loger dans les villes où ils
travaillent en cause la spéculation
causée par la financiarisation du
secteur immobilier vos nouvelles la
régulation financière est une compétence
de l'Union qu'attendez-vous donc pour
agir sur ce front explosif pas plus que
la nature les biens communs ou l'énergie
le logement ne peut être un simple actif
financier laissé aux aléas du marché
si la transition écologique est
solidaire doit être notre projet
fédérateur ne perdons jamais de vue que
notre union a d'abord une communauté de
valeurs or partout en Europe les
libertés fondamentales sont en danger
que ce soit au travers de la remise en
cause des droits des femmes le
sous-financement et la miss sous-tutelle
de la justice l'hyper-concentration des
médias l'espionnage de journalistes
d'activistes leader politique ou encore
les violences policières à rencontres de
manifestants et de personnes racisées
madame la Présidente malgré les
pressions juridiques et financières que
vous avez exercées sur deux États
membres les dérives se poursuivent et
s'accentuent en tant que gardienne du
droit européen la Commission va devoir
redoubler d'efforts et pas seulement à
l'égard de la Pologne ou de la Hongrie
speaking of fondamentale
dignité humaine il n'y a pas plus grand
mental que la façon dont nous traitons
les gens qui recherchent auprès de Nous
protection
de dictateur ou d'état qui n'en sont
plus pour l'éloigner les migrants de nos
côtes ça fait de l'union de la
Méditerranée une aiguille tombe de masse
et je ne suis pas d'accord avec votre
optimisme parce que le pacte
illimination ne change pas cette logique
mortifère l'Union pour devoir pour
responsabilités gérer comme besoin de
prendre sa part et d'accepter
d'accueillir ces personnes déplacées et
c'est possible simplement si nous
mettons ensemble nos capacités
c'est notre crédit moral qui est en jeu
et passe justement en Afrique pendant
des décennies la peur la migration était
instrumentalisée par l'extrême droite
mais maintenant il semble que la lutte
que le changement climatique est devenu
leur nouvelle objectif le nouvel cible
mais ce qui m'inquiète encore plus mais
la Présidente c'est le fait que de plus
en plus de collègues de votre partie
suivent cette même stratégie ce même
langage dans l'espoir peut-être de
ramener les électeurs dans le giron du
PPS différents partis membre du PPE on
choisit de faire des coalitions avec des
pratiques et certains leur représentants
n'ont même pas honte de me dire que ah
ils ont tellement en commun avec eux en
termes de valeur et de programmes donc
au nom des verres
où l'on s'en appel je ne sais pas le
parti de Robert Schuman s’éloignait de
ses valeurs fondamentales les valeurs
sur lesquelles on a construit l'Union
européenne
chers collègues et c'est ma conclusion
la pandémie et la guerre sur fond de
bouleversements climatique ont convaincu
la majorité de nos concitoyens que ce
n'est qu'ensemble que nous Européens
pourrons relever les défis de ce siècle
l'Union européenne a retrouvé crédit à
leurs yeux au point que même ceux ici
ils sont plus très nombreux d'ailleurs
même ceux ici qui plaidait la sortie de
leur pays n'oserait plus le faire
ouvertement aujourd'hui à nous de
consolider cette acquis en gardant le
cap et on nous assurant que les efforts
seront justement répartis c'est à ce
prix que notre union sera un espace de
paix et de liberté à la prospérité à la
fois partagée et durable nos concitoyens
et en particulier une jeunesse
légitimement anxieuse de son avenir n'en
n'attend pas moins de nous sachons
susciter et garder leur confiance je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
je donne maintenant la parole à Richardt
les goûts de CO pour 5 minutes pour le
groupe ECR
[Applaudissements]
est elle aujourd'hui dans un meilleur
état qu'il y a disons 20 ans de cela
et bien c'est un grand nom
paraphraser Shakespeare et Hamlet de
Shakespeare il y a quelque chose de
pourri dans l'état de l'Union
plus que jamais nous notons les tensions
les conflits les instabilités
incertitudes c'est ce que nous voyons au
plan économique avec une flambée de
l'inflation
avec les experts toujours plus inquiets
de perspectives néfastes et la récession
qui est à l'horizon et ceci cette de
votre fait madame la Présidente de la
Commission avec les sanctions aussi en
effet porter à la Russie ce qui est une
bonne chose mais n'oublions pas qu'avant
alors la Commission européenne n'avait
pas
osé faire quelque chose de cette
alliance Germano russe et avec ce refus
d'agir la commission porte une
responsabilité face à cette dette
actuelle la politique migratoire n'est
qu'un échec malgré les efforts
rhétoriques les vies de propos de la
Commission européenne nous voyons que
les passeurs
sont en poche de grands profits et que
les flux illégaux continuent nous voyons
le nombre de morts de pillage de viol
qui augmente nous avons par exemple 40
viols pour 100
000 en France en Allemagne alors qu'il
n'y en a que deux dans mon pays le pacte
vert c'est le projet phare de la
commission est plutôt que d'être un
vecteur de croissance ce n'est qu'une
extravagance très coûteuse
300 milliards à l'horizon 2030 avec la
flambée du coût de la ville factures
énergétique et tous les autres aspects
très désagréables générés par ce
fantasme de la commission elle a
commission et cela n'est pas l'objet de
surprises
sur la question
la dernière fantasy cyniste et celle de
la loi sur la restauration de la nature
et c'est Monsieur Timmermans qui sous
tendait cette initiative et qui vient de
partir par la petite porte une façon
bien aisée pour retourner sur la scène
politique nationale j'espère que ces
électeurs lui donneront ce qu'il mérite
notre fantaisie
d'être commune de 800 milliards d'euros
d'ici 2026 nous savons que les
perspectives étaient erronées le coût de
tout ceci sera certainement deux fois
plus élevé que prévu le budget européen
est un chaos moins de 66 milliards
d'euros
l'heure d'aujourd'hui vous avez mal
calculé les marchés auraient dû avoir
plus de confiance dans la crédibilité
financière de l'Union européenne que
dans celle des États membres c'était un
pari
erroné vous avez considéré la propagande
européenne comme la réalité et
finalement
les politiques lorsque je compare
l'ancienne Commission avec la vôtre ce
que je note c'est un recul vers toujours
plus d'oligarchie et moins de respect
face à ce que stipule les traités la
commission devient une machine partisane
qui s'immisce dans la politique
nationale pour tenter de mettre de côté
les gouvernements qui lui déplaisent
vous madame la Présidente avec voté les
électeurs avaient lancé un avertissement
menacé les électeurs Italiens vont des
élections leur disant attention si les
choses ne prennent pas la bonne voie
nous avons des instruments entre les
mains je vous rappelle que vous ne
disposez pas d'instruments pour
interférer dans les processus
démocratiques des États-nations monsieur
au cash and Co dispose de ces outils
vous n'en avez pas
[Applaudissements]
vous en avez fait une caricature il
existe un ancien proverbe aller médecin
se soignent eux-mêmes
soignez-vous vous-même c'est ce que je
vous dis madame la Présidente la
Commission devrait arrêter de jongler
avec les bases juridiques en disant que
les taxes ne sont pas des taxes mais
plutôt des contributions et en mettant
ainsi de côté les procédures nécessaires
vous devriez fournir tous les documents
pertinents liés à l'accord sur les
vaccins se compris vos échanges SMS
[Applaudissements]
de voir comment l'on doit respecter les
règles un dernier point
se retrouvera dans une page de manuel
d'histoire comme étant celle qui a tenté
de réglementer la langue de l'Union
européenne
avec une forme dans doctrinement
enracinée dans le texte par exemple en
interdisant certains mots
projeter tout ceci avec les injonctions
de la Commission européenne en nous
imposant la façon dont nous devons nous
exprimer et éviter par exemple le terme
de Noël cette absolument
indignant c'est en outrage mais cela
nous permet de voir dans les coulisses
le fonctionnement de la commission et
cela devrait être un avertissement lancé
à chacun d'entre nous
président de groupe ID Marco tsani 2030
plus un programme électoral qui lance
une campagne pour un nouveau mandat à la
tête de la commission mais sincèrement
à penser que les armes que nous avait
annoncé réponse aux crises que traverse
les toits européens
soit vraiment tout ce que la Commission
à l'intention de faire au cours des
prochains mois et je voudrais reprendre
le point par point les questions que
vous avez évoquées voilà commencez par
le pacte vert
nous avons une occasion historique il
faut moins d'idéologie plus de
pragmatisme pour cette transition et au
départ du commissaire Timmerman
vous avez l'occasion de remettre cette
transition sur la bonne voie
en partant de réflexion qui doivent être
exprimés clairement quand on parle de
changement climatique
le problème ce n'est pas l'Union
européenne le problème aux agriculteurs
le problème c'est pas nos entreprises
des problèmes
il faut moins d'aider de logis plus de
pragmatisme sinon le seul vainqueur de
cette transition sera pas à
l'environnement ce ne sont pas les
citoyens européens ce sera la Chine
les premiers signes
maintenant deuxième point vous avez dit
que la Commission met l'intention d'agir
sur cette question avec
une enquête sur les subventions à la
question c'est bon aujourd'hui en 2023
la commission encore besoin de lancer ce
genre d'enquête sur ce sujet alors que
il est tout à fait clair que la Chine se
livre est concurrence déloyale même mon
fils de moins de 5 ans le sait déjà
alors on ne veut pas d'enquête ce que ce
que nous voulons c'est que la Commission
fasse qu'elle doit faire pour protéger
nos entreprises à poser des droits à
ceux qui ne respectent pas les règles
maintenant votre deuxième proposition
vous avez annoncé une enquête sur
l'impact de la bureaucratie j'ai bien
compris vous avez l'intention de nommer
un envoyé spécial qui sera là comme un
lien entre vous et les PME alors encore
une fois
je suis stupéfait pas besoin spéciale
les élus ici de ce Parlement sont des
envoyés spéciaux nous qui chaque jour
parlons avec les entreprises nous
n'avons pas besoin de mener des enquêtes
des comités ou je ne sais quoi ce qu'il
faut c'est moi le bureau si les
entreprises valent moins de règles moins
de loi des lois mieux faites et plus de
liberté alors ça ne semble plus être une
priorité pour la Commission européenne
maintenant dernier point l'immigration
de disposition d'initiative mais j'ai
l'impression que la Commission ne veut
toujours pas résoudre la question et
le poids des flux migratoires
insupportables retombe sur peu de pays
ça semble satisfaire les autres alors là
c'est très simple tant que la ligne de
l'Union européenne cette question ne
sera pas claire à savoir ceux qui n'ont
pas le droit d'entrer de Lyon peine
doivent rester en dehors que
l'immigration illégale est un délit et
qu'on ne peut pas parler de
redistribution si on ne réduit pas les
départs alors tant qu'on aura pas suivi
cette ligne on ne résoudra pas le
problème alors je souhaite vraiment coco
de prochains moi on change de cap et
connaissait de les plus de place à ce
que de moi les citoyens et pour ça il y
a besoin de comité ou d'envoyer moi je
pense que c'est assez clair merci bon
travail merci la parole est à Martine
childammann pour le groupe de la gauche
vous avez 4 minutes
politique ne se mesure pas à l'aune des
propos tenus madame Vander la hyène dans
de grands discours ou à des constats
d'autosatisfaction mais à la réalité
concrète vous parlez d'histoires vous
parlez de moments où l'homme atterri sur
la lune de justice sociale de protection
des animaux de respect de dignité ce
dont sont autant de concepts que vous
évoquez et ensuite vous annoncez toute
une série d'initiatives et en bref vous
promettez la lune aux européennes c'est
aux Européens mais la réalité est tout
autre pour un simple travailleur dans
l'Union européenne l'année dernière on a
un simple ouvrier de lieu voyez son
salaire reculé de 4% l'année dernière
cette croyais là il peut plus permettre
de vacances bien mérité avec sa famille
parce que l'électricité le chauffage le
loyer sont de plus en plus cher c'est
ouvrier là qui comprend plus rien quand
vous parlez de la justice sociale et
lorsque vous ne dites pas un seul mot de
la difficulté pour les travailleurs de
l'Union européenne pour une mère
célibataire le discours sur la fameuse
garantie pour l'enfance ou la
compétitivité européenne
semble
à du cynisme pur pourquoi parce que elle
elle se bat au quotidien et pendant la
durée de votre président le prix de la
nourriture a augmenté de 34% et elle
elle essaye simplement de mettre les
repas sur la table vous n'avez rien fait
contre Laurent gervissement de la vie
vous avez encouragé la spéculation vous
ne l'avez pas vous n'y avez pas mis un
terme vous avez laissé les prix
augmenter sans aucune mesure vous n'avez
pas introduit une taxe qui devait
permettre de résoudre le problème et qui
on paye le plus lourd tribus ce sont les
jeunes il y a 59 millions de personnes
qui dans l'Union européenne sont
menacées de propreté voilà le bilan
auquel
sur lequel on vous jugera de votre
prestation j'ai eu l'occasion de
rencontrer
retraités dans ma circonscription il
touche une pension de 660 euros après
avoir travaillé toute sa vie c'est trop
peu pour vivre et c'est le cas d'un
retraité sur quatre dans l'Union
européenne qui ne peuvent pas vivre dans
la dignité avec cette pension donc vous
vous êtes à des années-lumière des
préoccupations de ces hommes et de ses
femmes la maison Europe dans laquelle
tous devraient avoir un toit et devenu
un taudis délabré et ça c'est aussi
votre responsabilité politique Madame la
Commissaire ce moment historique en fait
il ne fonctionne pas il se heurte à la
dure réalité et concrète et que
faites-vous vous
en dépit de tout bon sens économique
vous vous accrochez à marcher d’énergie
défaillant à la règle d'or en matière
d'endettement européen et vous
entretenez des paradis fiscaux mais nous
ne parlons pas ici tout simplement d'une
petite guerrillage jardinière mais bien
de la manière dont vous comprend mettez
les investissements dans l'avenir et le
renforcement des services publics et
malgré les propos que vous tenez vous
mettez à mal justement les services
publics et vous ne menez pas la lutte
contre la pauvreté en fait vous mettez
des bâtons dans la dans les roues de la
lutte contre la pauvreté ça frise le
déni de réalité politique et la
l'existence même de la population est
menacée et pendant ce temps-là les
grandes énerves les entreprises
énergétiques les groupes
agroalimentaires les géants de
l'immobilier et surtout l'industrie de
l'armement continue d'empêcher de très
juteux bénéfices
moi franchement je me pose la question
comment est-ce que vous arrivez encore à
dormir n'y voyez pas une attaque
personnelle 11000 personnes sont
d'autres aux frontières extérieures
depuis 2019 7 morts pour chaque jour de
votre président et vous vous parlez de
respect de dignité d'humanité les camps
continuent d'exister les politiques de
refoulement continuent d'être des
réalités ça n'a strictement rien à voir
avec le respect et la dignité donc
cesser de tenir des grands discours
mettez en œuvre une politique à la
hauteur des enjeux de la population et
mettait fin à ce manque de respect
vis-à-vis de la vie de l'homme et de la
femme européenne et c'est ainsi que nous
pouvons enfin mettre en place la
démocratie et la justice sociale et
l'écologie nous appelons de nos vœux
mais pour cela il faudra que la
politique de la Commission européenne
s'en prennent davantage aux riches
groupes agro-industrielles
maintenant vous avez la parole merci
au cours de ces quatre années vous avez
trouvé que vous étiez plus une
marathonienne que le sprinter et ça en
politique c'est un atout mais je voulais
vous faire une suggestion
au cours de cette dernière année le
travail continue à poursuivre uniquement
le bien commun et l'avenir européenne et
n'écoutez pas les sirènes de certaines
capitales européennes notre objectif
votre objectif ça doit pas être le
Conseil européen de juin 2024 mais 2050
la date à laquelle nous devrons
recueillir les fruits des politiques
d'aujourd'hui pour le mouvement 5
étoiles l'Europe ne doit pas prendre
comme modèle l'austérité de 2011-2012
mais next generation de 2020 le pacte de
stabilité donc ça peut pas être un
copier-coller des erreurs du passé sur
l'avenir la rampe de lancement pour une
Europe plus verte plus technologique
plus sociale et plus juste madame la
Présidente la guerre en Ukraine c'est la
principale menace
pour l'avenir pour la vie des citoyens
européens mettons-y un terme
seul la diplomatie le dialogue pourront
ramener la paix sur notre continent pas
les armes merci
je rends maintenant la parole à la
présidente de la Commission européenne
c'est la fin de Airlines pour 5 minutes
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
merci pour vos réponses pour la
discussion que nous avons entamée ici
ensemble vous le savez avec l'état de
l'Union ce n'est pas uniquement un
discours à prononcer mais c'est
également une lettre d'intention que
j'ai publié
et également un nombre limité de
nouvelles initiatives permettez-moi de
rappeler certains initiatives
mentionnées tout d'abord en matière
d'état de droit
l'État de droit est le ciment de notre
union
et nous avons pu mettre en place le
paquet historique next generation
qu'il était de première importance
d'investir dans l'Union européenne
de l'argent des contribuables européens
et c'est la raison pour laquelle il
existe
une obligation très stricte à savoir
mettre en place des réformes dans les
États membres et les connecter avec ce
budget dans certains États membres nous
notons des problèmes d'État de droit et
nous avons connecté ceci avec les
investissements au titre de Next
Generation
il est tout à fait inacceptable qu'en
est un membre
souhaite obtenir les fonds au titre d'un
next generation et où sans opérer les
réformes sur lesquelles nous nous étions
entendus lorsque nous avions signé le
contrat sur ce next generation si vous
voulez les fondus des contribuables
européens pour des investissements dans
votre pays vous devez vous soumettre aux
règles de l'État de droit et opérer les
réformes nécessaires
un deuxième point sur nos capacités de
défense
tout d'abord je tourne mon regard vers
le passé en observant l'Ukraine nous
savons que nous voulons la paix en
Ukraine mais nous voulons une tête
durable une pêche juste et pour ce faire
nous avons du crème on a besoin de
garantir de sécurité
une nouvelle attaque russe et c'est là
que l'Union européenne entre en scène en
garantissant la sécurité à long terme de
l'Ukraine avec des implications très
fortes pour notre industrie européenne
de la défense cette industrie de la
défense qui travaille à plein régime
nous le savons mais ce n'est pas
suffisant car pour permettre cette
dissuasion ukrainienne nous devons
encore accélérer augmenter nos capacités
militaires c'est ce que nous faisons
avec ASAP l'acte sur les la production
des munitions et j'aimerais remercier le
Parlement et le Conseil d'avoir fait ce
texte on entend record regardons
également ce que nous pouvons faire au
delà des munitions en cyber défense
défense maritime ou aériennes par
exemple ce sont des projets européens
par nature aucun État membre ne peut
faire cavalier seul sur ces éléments
nous avons besoin d'une coopération
européenne pour la recherche et le
développement mais aussi sur le front
industriel et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous allons travailler sur une
stratégie de la défense l'industrie de
la défense pour aider l'industrie de la
défense accélérer la production
d'équipements toujours en synergie avec
l'OTAN cette essentiel pas de goulet
d'étranglement qui devrait nous empêcher
de fournir un soutien nécessaire à
l'Ukraine un troisième point que je
voulais évoquer car cela était mentionné
par bon nombre de
députés c'est le pacte vert européen
la politique est toujours personnelle et
pendant ce mandat depuis 2019
dans ma famille trois petits enfants je
n'étais pas grand-mère avant ce début de
mandat
et depuis ce mandat cette expérience
tout accueillir trois petits bébés sur
notre planète
a changé ma conviction profonde que
j'avais pour l'avenir de ses enfants
parce que ma perspective est très
limitée mais lorsque je vois ces enfants
ou en réalité ses bébés se nourrissons
en âge d'être scolarisés en 2050 ils
seront peut-être eux-mêmes en train de
fonder leur propre famille et je ne
cesse de me poser la question
auront-ils la même vie ce qu'ils auront
les quatre saisons que nous connaissions
lorsque nous étions enfants quels seront
quel sera leur avenir seront-ils en
mesure d'avoir une famille quel sera le
monde autour de
je sais que tout ceci
définit la façon dont nous allons
trancher la question du pacte vert
européen donc Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés ce que je peux vous dire ici
c'est que à titre personnel je suis
extrêmement investir pour le PACS vers
européen car je sais qu'il en va de
notre survie et que cela est absolument
essentiel pour notre prospérité à
l'avenir si nous y parvenons et nous y
arriverons si nous sommes unis
où vous venez de suivre le discours sur
l'état de l'Union d'Ursula vendeur
lionne la présidente de la Commission
européenne cette exprimée pendant
environ une heure elle a inventé son
bilan et les défis à relever pour les
prochaines années dernier discours sur
l'état de l'Union pour cette présidente
puisque nous sommes à quelques mois des
élections européennes qui se tiendront
le 9 juin prochain alors ce sont bilan
et bien Ursula vendeur lionne a inventé
l'écologie avec le pacte vert ou
l'indépendance énergétique elle a pour
les très grands défis à relever par les
de la pénurie de main d'oeuvre de
l'inflation qui devrait mettre du temps
à revenir à 2% et puis de l'idée de
faciliter l'activité des entreprises
elle a aussi vanter un nouveau pacte
pour la migration et l'asile elle a
aussi fait quelques annonces sur les
violences faites aux femmes inscrire
dans le droit à la protection des femmes
et puis l'ouverture d'une enquête sur
les subventions voitures électriques en
Chine pour lutter contre la concurrence
déloyale elle a également dit que
l'avenir de l'Ukraine se trouvait dans
notre union en plaidant pour un
plaidoyer pour l'élargissement en
faisant pourquoi pas évoluer les traités
Sylvain vous êtes à mes côtés vous êtes
professionnel à Sciences Po spécialiste
de l'Europe vous avez suivi ce discours
d'Ursula wander lionne alors qu'est-ce
que vous vous retenez de ce de ce
discours est-ce que elle a évidemment
vanté son bilan mais on a aussi entendu
après les différents groupes politiques
s'exprimés et formuler quelques
critiques sur la migration sur le pacte
vert sur les règles budgétaires
quel finalement quelle conclusion vous
en tirez il me semble que évidemment
elle allait évidemment vous le dites
elle a inventé son bilan c'est sûr qu'on
pouvait pas attendre autre chose mais il
me semble qu'elle l'a fait de façon
assez talentueuse je porte pas un
jugement de valeur mais je veux dire
assez habile c'est-à-dire que en effet
elle est partie
du disque de son discours d'investiture
en disant j'avais un programme et avec
ma commission a-t-elle dit c'est 26
commissaires on a accompli à peu près
tout ce pourquoi vous m'aviez investi il
y a 4 ans et demi 90% elle dit 90%.
alors je sais pas comment elle arrive à
chiffrer mais
c'est vrai que saufeur de ma part on
n'est jamais complètement omniscient
bien entendu surtout comme ça à chaud
mais je pense que ce qu'elle dit est
exact c'est à dire que elle avait un
programme effectivement assez précis
parce qu'il faut bien avoir en tête que
l'Union européenne si vous voulez elle a
les États membres confient à l'Union
européenne des compétences qui sont
assez bien circonscrites c'est-à-dire on
connaît assez bien les règles du jeu et
la limite du terrain donc à partir de là
c'est vrai que c'est assez possible de
dire pour une commission européenne
quatre ans et demi plus tard ben voilà
vous m'aviez investi sur ce programme et
vous pouvez reprendre les points un par
un et bah c'est vrai qu'on a fait
beaucoup de choses alors vouloir vous
leur appeliez Brigitte le numérique il y
a eu des choses de faire la politique
vis-à-vis de la Chine
alors maintenant par rapport à votre
question il me semble que ce qui est
intéressant c'est de dire oui en effet
beaucoup de choses de ce qui avait été
annoncé ont été accomplis alors accompli
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que la
Commission a eu le talent de parvenir à
faire voter parce que la Commission elle
elle tient la gendar les législatif mais
c'est pas elle qui vote les textes elle
est parvenue à faire en sorte que les
deux que les deux assemblées disons
l'équivalent de ce qui serait le
Parlement dans son ensemble c'est à dire
d'une part le Parlement européen on va
dire l'assemblée des citoyens et d'autre
part le Conseil de l'Union européenne
c'est-à-dire la chambre des États en
fait voilà dans lequel il y a un
représentant par état elle est parvenue
à faire en sorte que ces deux chambres
votent 90% elle l'a dit comme ça de son
programme certes maintenant c'est pas
pour ça que ce programme résout tous les
problèmes c'est à dire que dire par
exemple que on est devenu que l'Europe
est devenue on va dire le leader mondial
de la protection des droits dans le
domaine du numérique c'est sans doute
vrai il y a deux textes très très
importants qui ont été votés et que même
parfois les États-Unis ou l'Inde
regardes comme on les Européens ont fait
pour faire la même chose chez eux mais
ça vient quand même masquer le fait que
les Européens dans leur ensemble c'est
pas la commission c'est les Européens
disons les gafams les grandes
entreprises du secteur numérique elles
sont pas en Europe
[Musique]
les grandes entreprises de données et
l'utilisation des données des datas on
est quand même en retard et le fait est
que par rapport à 2008 si on compare à
il y a maintenant un écart qui est de
80% entre le PIB par habitant dans
l'Union européenne et le PIB par
habitant aux États-Unis donc là je fais
un commentaire si vous voulez c'est très
très bien d'être à la fois en avance si
j'ose dire ou d'être un peu la tête de
pont avancée du monde dans le domaine de
la protection des droits par rapport à
l'économie numérique ou même par rapport
à la transition écologique mais il se
trouve que sur le plan comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait appeler ça à la fois de
l'innovation et on peut le voir avec les
voitures électriques et également
simplement du développement économique
alors justement puisque vous en parlez
parmi les grands défis qui restent à
relever ils sont souvent d'ordre
économiques et elle a justement lancé
annoncé l'ouverture d'une enquête pour
lutter contre les subventions aux
voitures électriques en Chine donc ça
est-ce que c'est une avancée qui est
importante parce que ça a été aussi
critiqué qu'est-ce que finalement ça va
ça va donner ce qu'il faut vraiment
aider davantage
les entreprises européennes dans cette
lutte contre la concurrence déloyale et
puis au-delà de ça il y a le problème
économique avec une inflation qui mettra
du temps elle dit à revenir à 2% alors
sur le sur les voitures électriques
là pour moi c'est clair elle a bien
compris et la Commission a bien compris
donc la commission c'est 27 commissaires
et à peu près 25 à 30000 fonctionnaires
qui font tourner l'Europe tous les jours
et 24 heures sur 24 on va dire comme ça
ils ont compris que là tout d'un coup il
y a eu le soleil en automobile parce que
c'était à Munich je crois ils ont
compris que sur la voiture électrique là
les Européens en gros sont restés sur la
ligne de départ et les Chinois et les
Coréens et les Japonais sont partis très
loin alors qu'est-ce que l'Union
européenne pas les Européens qu'est-ce
que l'Union européenne a en magasin pour
faire face à ça elle a la politique de
la concurrence les Européens ça c'est
comme ça depuis 1957 traditionnellement
il y a pas de politique industrielle en
Europe les politiques industrielles
elles sont nationales on va dire comme
ça alors elle dégaine
elle dégaine effectivement une enquête
sur les éventuels sur une suspicion de
subventions déloyale que l'État chinois
verseraient au constructeur chinois de
voitures électriques ils vont peut-être
trouver les choses ils vont peut-être
rien trouvé mais
moi j'ai quand même tendance à dire que
c'est un peu prendre les choses par le
petit bout de la lorgnette le vrai
problème c'est que ça fait 20 ans que
les industriels de l'automobile chinoise
qui était évidemment traditionnellement
très très en arrière des européennes des
Américains ont mis le paquet à la fois
sur la construction de la batterie
électrique et sur la construction des
véhicules électriques faut pas oublier
qu'entre parenthèses c'est quand même
Tesla qui a un constructeur américain
musk qui est quand même le numéro 1
mondial et pendant ce temps là les
grands constructeurs
européens Fiat Mercedes BMW Renault
stelantis et tout ce que vous voulez
ils ont à peu près du retard sur ces
deux sujets alors est-ce que il va
vraiment on va vraiment découvrir qu'il
y a eu des subventions des loyales on
verra en tous les cas est-ce que ça
annonce c'est ça que moi j'entends
l'éventualité d'une stratégie de mise en
place d'un protectionnisme européen aux
frontières de l'UE
si c'était le cas
elle ouvre la porte implicitement ça
serait une grande première sur
l'inflation ben oui effectivement ça a
été rappelé par les leaders des groupes
parlementaires qui lui ont répondu le
gros problème aujourd'hui c'est
l'inflation et en particulier en
particulier pardon l'inflation
des produits de la vie quotidienne
l'inflation alimentaire
est un vrai problème le pouvoir d'achat
est devenu un vrai problème donc là
aussi il me semble que à la fois juste
titre et très habilement elle a parlé
d'une réduction historique du taux de
chômage et disons d'un taux d'emploi qui
est historique dans l'Union européenne
mais qu'est-ce que ça masque ça masque
d'une part qu'il y a un gros problème
démographique là évoqué elle dit sur le
marché le marché du travail est très
tendu ça ça veut dire quoi bon ben voilà
on le sait la population européenne est
vieillissante depuis 30 ans bon ben
voilà on en paye aujourd'hui le prix sur
le marché du travail mais ça masque
aussi effectivement que il y a un gros
problème de pouvoir d'achat de
stagnation voir de régression du revenu
pas seulement même si c'est évidemment
très très important et très dommageable
pour les personnes disons pauvre ou pour
les classes
disons dites populaires mais aussi pour
les classes moyennes donc on va élargir
un petit peu en parlant aussi de
l'international elle est revenue bien
évidemment
Ursula vendeur lionne sur le soutien à
l'Ukraine je vous propose d'ailleurs
qu'on la réécoute nous avons proposé 50
milliards d'euros supplémentaires sur
quatre ans pour investir et pour
réformer
nous sommes contribuera à bâtir l'avenir
de l'Ukraine afin de reconstruire un
pays moderne et prospère cet avenir est
tout à fait clair
ce Parlement la déclaré au effort
l'avenir de l'Ukraine se trouve dans
notre union l'avenir des Balkans
occidentaux se trouve dans notre union
l'avenir de la Moldavie se trouve dans
notre union
donc l'avenir de l'Ukraine est bien dans
l'Union européenne toute façon ça ça ne
vient que confirmer une décision qui a
été prise au plus haut niveau par les
chefs d'États et de gouvernement qui est
de dire que il y a une perspective
d'adhésion de l'Ukraine et de la
Moldavie et que les négociations
d'adhésion ont commencé bon dans
l'histoire il y a certaines négociations
d'adhésion mettant avec la Finlande ou
la Suède qui ont duré trois ans avec
d'autres pays comme la Roumanie ou la
Bulgarie ça a duré plus de 15 ans donc
on n'y est pas encore mais la
perspective est confirmée moi ce qui me
paraît intéressant le signal faible que
j'entends c'est qu'elle enjambe en
disant cela
les objectifs de guerre alors que cela
fonder lion depuis 18 mois ses
caractérisé comme incarnant vraiment
disons la détermination des Européens à
soutenir les Ukrainiens à sanctionner
les Russes et à aller le plus loin
possible dans une victoire ukrainienne
une victoire militaire et dans le fait
que l'Ukraine recouvrerait l'ensemble de
son territoire et là elle en a assez peu
parlé donc
je sais pas ce que ça signifie en termes
de mettons quels sont les objectifs
entre guillemets dans la guerre
d'invasions mais en tous les cas la
perspective du Ukraine dans l'UE est
confirmé ça c'est sûr merci Sylvain Ken
de nous avoir accompagné d'avoir
décrypté ce discours de cela vendeur
lion dernier discours sur l'état de
l'Union de la présidente de la
Commission européenne avant elle les
élections je vous remercie de nous avoir
accompagné je rappelle votre livre
Sylvain à Cannes l'histoire de la
construction de l'Europe depuis 1945 et
c'est aux éditions puff merci à vous
tous de nous avoir suivis et très bonne
suite de programme sur LCP
[Musique]